as chair of the house edna
subcommittee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of covert 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
reserve and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during the
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available to the house in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules in rsa 91a anyone who
has a problem accessing the meeting
should call 603-271-3600
or email
hcs
dot leg.state.nbc
dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state where
whether there's anyone in the room with
you during the meeting which is required
under the right to know law
in my office
representative schultz
good morning i am in concord at my home
and my husband will be in and out of the
room
representative lucas
i'm at home and my wife will be uh
around
representative lonzara
home and some family members throughout
and
i am here
and that's it for the subcommittee
did i miss anybody
no you got everybody
excellent
okay um so when last we met we agreed on
the content of the bill as drafted
except for an amendment that would
change it so that it was clearly
delineated that all costs for membership
in the compact would be incurred
and taken care of by oplc did everyone
get a copy of the amendment
yes
anyone have any questions or thoughts on
the amendment
good it sounds like we're all in
agreement
so based on that
i am going to go ahead and
call the role we'll vote on this
amendment or vote on the on the bill
as amended
for referral to the full committee
and i will move out to pass with
amendment
don't you have to move the amendment
first mr chair
i don't know if i have to do it that way
in a subcommittee
um
pam do i have to do it that way in the
subcommittee
yeah we usually mirror the same
approach
that we do in the world i mean it's it's
certainly casual but
yeah um the only reason is because i
don't have like an amendment number or
anything but um
right it's more a conceptual you know
you can refer to the broderick
amendment you know
okay
okay in that case i will move the
broderick suggested amendment
any second
uh it just looks basically like we
agreed to it's pretty straightforward so
yeah
exactly what we agreed to any further
discussion
seeing none i will call the role
representative grota
mcguire can you put yourself a mute or
something a lot of talking and i can't
hear
representative roy
sorry yes would you please
do this
sure i'll meet you
thank you
okay representative schultz i didn't
hear you
yes okay thank you representative
yes
representative lunzara
and the chair of ogs
that's unanimous
um
i now move the um uh
section five as amended excuse me seven
or five we're going all right
roy do you want to talk about the issue
of the uh the drafting error
um
yeah um
i thought we'd discuss it more in full
committee but if you wouldn't mind pam
if you could just give a quick uh brief
to the to the subcommittee on what what
we're what we're going to have to do
sure i wouldn't mind it
it's um it sounds a little a lot more
confusing than it really is but there's
just a drafting error on pages three and
four of the bill
which is the very beginning of part five
and and if you look at page three
line 32 you can see that
they're adding language about the
audiology and speech language pathology
compact to 329 d2
and you see section 1 there
but then if you look on page 4 line 17
the same language is repeated only it's
inserted into 326 f15
which is where speech language pathology
the speech language pathology practice
act is
so
so there was some discussion about
apparently or some
some
competing ideas about whether this new
compact language should be put into a
new into 329d which is currently where
the psychology
compact is and they it looks like they
wanted to make 329 d
a a chapter with all occupational
compacts in it
but then alternatively there was a
thought to put it into the speech
language pathology practice act so we
just need to pick one that's all that's
all that really needs to be done and the
duplicative language removed from the
bill
so
what i had thought is i was going to
reach out one more time to oplc
just to ensure what their preference is
then discuss it at the full committee
to see which way we were going to go on
that um
it's not
go ahead i'm sorry what this is what i
say um tom broderick is here um
you know we can bring him over to to
talk about it if you want
yeah that'll be good just so we can get
the preference on it what they were
trying to do
sure
he's on his way
okay while we're waiting for him may i
say something
yeah go ahead representation
thank you very much for uh mr chairman
so uh
where you're headed i'm very comfortable
with but uh
the only thing is that because
this is a little bit a little bit tricky
uh and we have to make a decision as to
which the better way is to go uh
and
so
so that the full committee understands
what's going on uh uh it might be well
to
if if tom is going to be available
to talk to the full committee which i
think we're going to have
when carol maybe at 10 o'clock already
she is here muted
and i can't unmute the room from up here
so uh-huh okay um well it is that that's
just my thought
so that the full committee understands
that we're making kind of a fundamental
decision how we want to proceed and
having tom explain it to the full
committee so that we're all on board is
my thought
but
i'll defer to the
chair's judgment with regard to how we
want to proceed at this moment
uh thank you representative smith that
was my initial inclination but i'd still
if he's available for the subcommittee
just so we can all understand what we're
voting on oh oh i i totally i i totally
get it that the the subcommittee should
certainly be a prized initially uh so
that they do know what they're you know
what you're voting on it's just that
that we want to have the full committee
understand because we're making kind of
a commitment how we want to structure
this so
but i i think the the the
proceeding with the subcommittee at this
point is a is the right way to do it
pam when is the full committee meeting
to discuss the whole bill
you're going to have some discussions
this afternoon or this morning after the
other builds are exact
yeah okay so we can we can discuss it
again
quickly and we can i'm sure mr broderick
were available uh mr broderick can you
just give us a quick rundown which
direction you were trying to head with
that
uh thank you for having me i
so i don't think oplc has a strong
preference i think a we have a slight
preference for putting it in the
individual practice acts
and the reason for that really is if you
know if i'm a physical therapist i'm
going to know to look in my
physical therapy practice act um
for the statutes that govern
uh i might not know to go to a separate
chapter on compacts however i don't
think it's a strong preference i don't
think that should well that should not
kill
kill the compacts at all though
um and then to um
to get to representative schmidt's point
i'm happy to be there i'm planning on
um listening in the full uh
committee meeting and
i'll be on mute doing other work but i
can jump on whenever needed
okay i just wanted to get a quick uh
summary of what you were thinking and we
will discuss it at the full committee
and decide which way is the best way to
go for clarity purposes
i have to say i don't feel comfortable
right now
this if we're going to be doing
something if we haven't decided which
road we're going down at the beginning
and this point how can we vote on this
as a subcommittee
well because this isn't a substantive
change to the bill it's just the
drafting error as to which section of
the law it's going to go into
i think that if we
can vote
on the substantive part of the bill
with regard to the um to the amendment
we did
deciding as a full committee where to
put in law i think um at least the
subcommittee has has heard
and decided on the substance of the of
the proposed bill
and the the technicality the full
committee can decide on um i would just
like to make that recommendation that as
it is
um pending this a decision from the full
committee on where to put it in the bill
in
the statutes we can go ahead and vote
does that make sense to you
representative gordon
it does i'm still you know
as a result since we're
in the discussion mode about the bill
i do have some hesitancy about this
compact arrangement because
um
we have been in
compacts before
but
i don't necessarily
like being the first one or one of the
first ones
new hampshire to be one of the first
states
i like that i feel more comfortable if
they're a little bit more proven
and the argument is always well we want
to see to the table
and
i'm looking for other people in the
committee to convince me that this is a
good idea
um i'll respond first
um i believe that we are the state is a
member of numerous compacts already that
we've been this isn't the first
um
so i think we do have some experience
with how they work we would get the
whole seat at the table with this
particular compact but as far as
compacts in general go i believe that
we're a member of quite a few of them
already and have been for some time does
anyone else want to speak on that
yeah i think that that's part of what
she's saying and
uh representative grota correct me if
i'm wrong it sounds like one of your
concerns is
if we are one of the first to join this
particular compact that has a whole
other
layer of dimensions to it i personally
am comfortable with it in this case you
know it's like to me as long as the
profession
um
it says and the people in that
profession say that this is something
that they want
i have no problem with it you know there
are there is a disputed one that we're
taking up on a different
compact
um that's already in process but um
you know we have some different opinions
on that but for this one i don't think
we really heard any
opposition to this at all if i remember
correctly
correct you're correct
yeah and uh i'm comfortable with it as
well i mean
if uh
the the
practitioners and the board have no
problem with it it looks pretty
straightforward and we've dealt with
compacts before
i'm not sure you know what
what would go wrong that would give us
pause in doing this at this point
if i could just weigh in for a second
here again
uh i i think that uh i my understanding
is that the
that the stakeholders the practitioners
uh want this uh it's it's not being uh
imposed or
dictated by oplc it's the practitioners
who want it that's why we're proceeding
at all
right but i'd like to get i'd like to
get that confirmed so that uh so by one
of the practitioners so it's not
an assumption that turns out to be an
inaccurate
um
i mean mr broderick are you still there
i am yes oh am i needed no
no you're good go ahead uh yeah so the
in
um
in working on this this compact we
reached out to the associations here in
new hampshire the uh let's see it's the
new hampshire
occupational therapy association um
expressed that they're in strong support
um the speech language pathology
association you heard from the national
um representative um but
both the board and the
new hampshire chapters association are
on board with that
the audiology
association i i think i see that the um
someone from
that association might be on um or a
representative but uh
they
wanted at first to learn a bit more
about the compact so we went into their
meetings explained a bit how compacts
worked and they ended up um
uh i believe in support definitely not
opposing it i believe that they are
supportive so speech language pathology
association strongly supports ot
association strongly sports
um i believe that the
audiology
association um got to support but they i
know they don't oppose it
okay thank you
does that help you go ahead
oh this is representative schultz i was
just gonna say
i um
for whatever it's worth
would definitely support
um
in the error of how you know the
conflicting parts to included in the
specific parts of the law for those
professions
that um because i don't i guess they're
all in it's all in one part of the law
but i so then i would definitely be
supportive of it being in
that professions
section even though it looks like this
compact language might
be something that will be
sort of boilerplate from here on out on
um
jax if i understand that correctly but
including it specifically to these
professions
um
in that part of the law i would
definitely be supportive of that for
whatever that's worth
thank you uh i i tend to agree after
hearing from oplc um and we will put
that to the full committee to to make
that decision because that's that's kind
of a quality policy decision that will
affect all the compacts how we move
forward so it's better to have the full
committee weigh in on that and get
carol's input on that too
um
representative grower do you feel
comfortable voting on the uh on the on
the uh bill as amended
at this point for subcommittee purposes
yes i will say
and i'll bring this up in subcommittee
i'd like to know if these compacts are
audited
at some time or or a review is done of
the compact to see what the benefits
were for new hampshire and if there is
no benefit
then i would like to know how we can
withdraw ourselves from them so
um just let's just make a note of that i
do think that
it's easy to always move ahead with
something but when you don't look back
at what the ramifications were you can
lose sight of what you've done
or the effect of what you've done and i
think that it's important to do that
i think you're absolutely correct and i
i believe on one of the other bills we
heard testimony that they do track um
the use and benefit of the compact and
as far as withdrawal we see that process
coming up in
one of the other sections
um where a withdrawal attempt is being
made so um we will explore that i firmly
believe in some depth at the full
community meeting
um
okay so we're running on time here i'm
gonna go ahead since everyone seems to
be on board
i'm going to
call the roll on we'll actually know
first i'm going to move off the pass
with amendment
any one second
i
specified part 5
yes part 5
133 with amendment that's what the
amendment we just voted on not the
decision on uh how to fix the
duplication
that's correct
okay i'll second it
thank you
any further discussion
no but for
i'm sorry to be so picky but for
clarification we should probably
state the um and if i could let's insert
the um
it's the
part five it's the um
excuse me
it's the amendment from mr broderick
that we're
yeah that's what when we called the vote
it was the broderick amendment okay so
let's it ought to pass with the broad
right just you know
with the suggested amendment by uh mr
broderick from april 23rd
um
okay so uh representative grota
yes
representative schultz
representative leckus yes
representative lanzara
yes
and the chair votes yes uh unanimous
to move to the full committee um ought
to pass with the broader amendment with
the understanding that we are going to
discuss where it is placed in the
statute
and with that i will close the
subcommittee meeting thank you all very
much and we'll all talk again very soon
thank you
thanks good job
i hand over control of zoom to whoever's
next
should be representative
i believe so
i'm not sure if the room is still muted
send carol a text or something i suppose
she can hear you so i think she's on her
way
okay
[Music]
must
yes
you
okay
yes
so
hmm
[Music]
good question
and we need to read the script again
we did for the last subcommittee
work session this is
i'll let you make the call
all right so it is
it probably is a safer practice
[Music]
all right
i'll give give people a chance to get
warmed up i suppose
um
it is 10 o'clock
where this is the subcommittee on
senate bill 133
we're looking at the amendment 1162 h
this is i believe part 14.
it's a new sub-paragraph having to do
with child care licensing
uh let me run through
the
narrative the
the opening statement
uh in order to be safe i suppose
as chair of the subcommittee on the
aforementioned bills and senate bill 133
amendment 1162h
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor i'm just as sick of it
as you are
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with house rule 67 in the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2024 202004 this public body is
authorized to meet electronically please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the president to observe
listen contemporarily to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the calendar and general ford
website notice that this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem with this
meeting should call 271
or email
hcs house community services i guess hcs
at leg state nhus the usual extension
in the event that the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned to be scheduled please note
that all votes that are taken during
speeding should be done by roll call
vote
we will start by taking the roll call
attendance
uh i'm going to call
really everybody who is here i'm going
to then
talk about the
subcommittee
i guess it's the clerk in me
representative allegro president
representative in the room president
representative
fel bailey
president in the committee room
representative fellows are you with us
today
not yet representative funk knows
i am here at home alone
no
okay and uh you are a member of the
subcommittee okay
uh why i have problems with that name
representative goalie
all right i'm here at home and my wife
is in the other room
okay
say hello
uh representative grotiff
i'm here in my office alone
eavesdropping on the subcommittee i bet
representative judy
representative judy you're part of my
subcommittee where are you
okay representative lonzara
home and some family members around
okay representative lucas
i'm home my wife's around and uh i'm
listening in
representative mcguire
here in the committee room okay
representative o'brien
i'm present i'm home in nashua and i get
grandkids all over the bloody place good
for you representative pearson
representative roy
i am here in my truck alone
representative schmidt
i am house sitting at the home of a
friend
in portsmouth
i am alone otherwise
okay home alone representative
i am present at my home in pembroke
alone
i am not a member of this subcommittee
welcome aboard
representative schultz
you are here
representative
the clerk is here in the room
representative yakumovic
a
fair sprinkling of people the
subcommittee represented mcguire
is
present judy
except for judy maguire
o'brien
and
fontenot
is here uh and i am here
okay uh so there's
we'll
proceed
um
where we left off
was we were we had listened
we had heard in committee
are we doing part 14 or part 7 part 14.
i'm looking at the notice and i'm only
seeing 14.
okay yeah i think the status of seven is
that we're just
what i was
going to do is give a brief recap of
where we are on 14
and we had heard in committee
uh testimony uh from representative
walter and uh
nick williams
uh
responded introducing this amendment
because of the crisis the shortage of
uh
teachers
at the uh child at child care level
and
there was uh objection because
of watering down of standards
and while er i think if i'm reading the
committee correctly
i don't want to speak for anyone but i
hope i'm recapping this accurately the
committee was in support of the fact
that we did not want to see
standards watered down but there is
present crisis and the immovable force
versus the unmovable object of getting
working parents back into the workforce
um
probably at least in the short run
[Music]
we're misrepresenting some members of
the committee
we didn't want to
water watered-down standards we wanted
to make sure that they were not
excessively academic for the position
because
the issue is whether or not
they care child care is
primarily educational like a school or a
preschool
or whether it is
supervisor or kid
and that is does not require the
academic standards that urban childhood
education does
it's also less expensive
and
the issue
right now
is not that we don't have qualified
teachers for we it's we don't have hope
we don't have daycare workers who are
willing to work for what we're willing
to pay them
okay
in
regardless or
except
in either case
uh the committee felt that
this amendment
was that introduced by representative
walter was meritorious
uh there were some questions about
uh
there was a big question about
documented life's experience uh and we
heard objections to that because it was
not
defined
and
there were words came in
we had words that uh
gave specific examples of what life's
experience was and i had asked to
add
more closely related activities
and i think where we left off i hope
where we left off is that tom broderick
is going to
do something with that because i don't
have those words with me right now and i
that i think that can only mean that mr
broderick is working on that i hope he's
there somewhere
yeah i can't find those words either but
i have them is is this the email that
you um sent out carol
yes
okay just a moment because i made
comments to those words
and i didn't realize that we okay this
is the words that you had sent and this
was my comment
documented life experience shall include
work for a family care provider
service so this is these are the things
that
document life experience
work for a family care provider
service as a foster parent
work as a school teacher
work as a camp counselor
and experience as a group leader for
children in sports and other activities
such as scouts or little league
and you had spoken with mary jane
and she agreed that the wording would be
a good idea i'm not sure she agreed to
this wording but i know that she is to
the word it was a good idea because i
spoke to her separately about this
what my comments were
i think it's important that these
experiences include groups of children
fostering one child in your home is
different than being with a group of
children
so i wrote my suggestion was i'm sorry
it's very difficult to do this
without the words but
my i left the the sentences that
representative mcguire wrote and i added
each
in each of these cases the experience
that shall involve three or more
children during these
so i just don't think being one-on-one
with a child
is the same thing as being in a room
full of children and some of these life
experiences some of these experiences
that were mentioned in the wording did
not it did not
indicate that it was a group of children
that needed to be part of the experience
as opposed to a child
and i think that's important
but other than that i'm okay with the
words
that's all familiar
and if you would like i can forward this
to the committee
please do
um
before uh okay uh do we or do we have
any guests
i disagree with that the only one of
those
experiences that would be with a single
child would likely be a foster parent
which would which might equally be with
more than one
but if that does involve taking care of
a child who is not your own so i think
it's relevant
i'd also like to add that this is in
addition to the thousand hours of
supervised child care experience in a
licensed child care program
so if somebody got interested in taking
care of kids with a
single foster child and then spent 30
spent a thousand hours
which is approximately six months
working in a supervised child care in a
licensed child care program supervised
filed by a licensed
person with more experience and more
training and they're still interested
i think we should give them credit for
the foster care
i mean it's not as if that would be
their only experience with children
and i think adding
three minimum of three children is
excessively restricted well i think it's
it would
you can't avoid it with the other
activities
right absolutely
and that's do i understand that what do
you mean you can't avoid it if you are
doing any of the activities other than
um
foster care uh you're going to be
involving more than uh
you'll be involving several children
it's kind of hard to imagine little
league or uh
the other things that you're talking
about that
are enumerated involving less than fewer
than three children
so i'm not sure it's not if the question
is is your statement necessary
my statement well i'll let the committee
decide that
i do think it has to be fostering one
child
or having one child at home
i can just know i can tell you from my
own experience
is
is a breeze compared to having
two or three
having one you're focused on one person
one little person
and if something should happen if you're
if you're with two people and you're
you're taking care of one and one falls
down and hurts themselves who's watching
the other one
you have to be able to do that and i'm
not convinced that
fostering one child or having one child
is
any parent who has more than one child
can tell you this
so i don't know why this is such a
it's not restrictive it's common sense
i i disagree i know you do carol i mean
i'm sorry representing mcguire i know
you do
i think that the
dealing with multiple children in the
licensed child care system is enough to
cover that aspect of it where did you
have you have a foster child there you
are responsible for taking care of
and
being responsible for
a child who was not your own which is
one of the important distinctions and
why i included foster children foster
parent in this list of
experiences
you also get a chance to observe
some stages of growth which may or may
not be applicable to any other child but
at least you
get some experience in seeing how
children change
i
representative i don't see this as being
a practical a practical problem
i mean it's it's nice but i i don't see
it as
something we have to worry about i will
take your advice
representative jack and i respect the uh
the ability to have this conversation
and
um i'll think about it
well
it's not that what you're not saying
doesn't make sense it's just that i
think it's more or less self-correcting
i don't think is a practical matter day
to day if this paragraph is used in vote
that we're going to be finding a
situation involving um
fewer than three i think it's
it's like please do not read this sign
right
um i'm going to um i'm fine i don't
really i don't need to talk about this
anymore and i did send the words to
um
miss spar of smarling so if you could
please forward that to the committee
because i don't have everyone's
i'm sorry sure
i'm so sorry
yes i'll send it around to everybody
right now
that
this this wording change was in response
to a concern
by the licensing unit that
documented life experiences was too
vague and broad and unable to be
implemented properly so
we're specifying the kinds of life
experiences that we think are to be
considered
as documented life experience
in lieu of academic training
for
a an associate
i will agree with that
i have a couple more things
first um
is there any sentiment that we should
include free of phrase like or closely
related activity
i'm not hot about that but it seems like
because of this list is so it enumerates
if you work for the ymca but not the
ywca uh oh
you know do we
i'm i'm okay with that what do the other
members of the subcommittee differ
i'm sorry
representative side tech could you
repeat what you
that last
what i'm saying is there is a list of
specific
examples of what documented life's
experience is
and i'm saying if something got missed
if you can say it is a closely related
activity
and i use the example it's not here but
if let's say the list said ymca but you
work for the ywca well come on
right
so leaving us
that's my purpose
yeah
interpretation in a reasonable way
well i'm trying or closely related i
wanted i don't want this to be the barn
door
right not married to the idea it just
seemed like that was a
something useful to put in i agree with
you okay what's the best acceptance well
i don't detect strong feelings
carson fontenot or o'brien do you have
any concerns with that
i don't have any real concerns with it
um as long as it doesn't open that uh
the duo back up to the
being the description being too vague
that the reason we're having this
discussion to begin with
that's why i said or closely related we
have to assume people are reasonable in
the way they look at this that the fact
that you sold amway goods during summer
vacation does not qualify okay as a
closely related activity
a couple more uh
another
thing that i'd like to bring up
and that is do we want to is there any
reason to invoke rules here is there
anything that requires uh john carter to
look at this like i'm looking when i see
it this isn't this is put into their
rulemaking authority
okay so it's already it's already there
okay so that that takes care of that uh
the other thing that i'd like to mention
mr broderick are you on board here i
haven't seen him
trying to bring him on because i thought
sorry i don't remember this that he
would that someone was left with the
task of actually preparing something
that we would assemble as part of
the omnibus amendment that will be ms
marlin
this
smarling yes i'll bet you're on
i am on
exciting okay so at one point um
when we're talking about the beverage
manufacturer whoever is talking please
mute themselves
thank you
okay
uh
we
it sounds like we have the sub company
is willing to feed the
the the grota words put in with as and
as close uh
or closely related activity
that phrase
and
coupled with the grota
language
uh we'd like to see
actually it's the mcguire language
representative scitec oh
oh
well
my language my my edition was not
accepted by the committee but okay
representative was just able to find the
words
okay uh
mr chairman
go speak mr representative o'brien uh
thank you um and i'm all in favor of
this and i think that the committee has
done a fine job giving specific examples
uh but what about putting the uh
something else in there we gave the
examples but as mentioned
other
similar type of responsibilities
maintained by the candidate you know and
that would be a little bit more
conclusive yet it throws the power back
to the hiring and the responsibility
back to the hiring source
so they could jeopardize themselves if
they don't
pay attention to our examples and
everything but it might be a little bit
more inclusive instead of being specific
i think that's your amendment
i think that i i think i used
i used my words for your idea
good okay
all right that's the only two bits i got
to it yeah okay sure enough and
representative wrote it when you said
your idea wasn't accepted it's kind of
harsh uh you're
no no it's not harsh i i don't mean to
be harsh at all
i'm saying i don't want to sound that
way the the fact is that you had a good
idea which is self-correcting well i
wasn't no but i wasn't panning your idea
that's what i'm saying of course i
didn't mean it that way and if you took
my words that way i thought it was not
my intent and i apologize
okay
so
where we're left with is
with those words uh
miss smarling if you would craft those
together i think our business has done
the love well
i think we should take a vote on
recommending this amendment
as amended
to with the with the revised language to
the full committee with the smarter
anyway i will so move that we recommend
this new sub-paragraph
as part 14 of
senate bill 133
and can i just clarify that we're we're
just adding one sentence to the end of
the
the amendment
that
is about documented life experience but
and the only
addition is at the end of the sentence
it says such as scouts or little league
or a closely related activity
right
okay yeah okay
uh madam chairman uh through the uh
chairman if i may ask a question too
uh this seems
to be because of the pandemic and and
the difficulty and talking to the good
people in nashua
it goes many much more uh type of places
are looking for help the other day i
went to demoulas and the butcher asked
me if i wanted a part-time job you know
i thought there was a cut up no pun
intended but
however
should this should we contemplate a
sunset to this if we see better times or
sunsets are usually a problem i
understand that
representative o'brien if you're here in
two years introdu
uh have
repealed will repeal the bill because we
don't know where we're going
okay now that's a fair answer i just uh
wonder if it might be a possibility but
thank you mr chairman i happen to like
sunsets too but i don't also see a lot
of uncertainty out there i'd love
also like to see how this works and
people are very
people don't have hesitate to bring in
repeals except for itinerant peddlers
the uh
other thing that i might mention to you
representative o'brien is you're
probably you and i are probably the only
two people left on the planet that still
call it the moles
just wanted to say just throw that in
yes and i'd like to comment on that
nothing not the market basket experience
the shortage of child care workers has
been going on a great deal longer than
the pandemic
and this is a way to
ease people into it without requiring
them to take
uh
30 hours as a substantial amount of
academic qualifications they still have
to have some and they need to do the
continuing education
but this will get people into the
business
and let them start working
before they have to make the commitment
on the uh
on the academics and i think that is
important
if i'm done i agree madam chair i would
like to add to you because i'm sure
everyone read the report that miriam
sent that
but um
just to say that the study committee
that looked at the business environment
for child care providers
uh that report was written pre-covered
and this was among the suggestions of
how to
um improve
the business of child care providing and
i think overall it just helps
people who need
uh child care in general uh i think the
other recommendations were good too
and i think we should look at those and
the ones that pertain to our committee
but there are still a few that haven't
been implemented
and yeah this child care crisis predates
code but for sure
i think there is a thank you
the study on house bill 230
is the appropriate place to consider
that because we'll have the whole summer
to work on it
just for my own understanding
this is more on the job training people
get started but they still have to meet
all the criteria that exist it's just
that we're getting getting them their
foot in the door
right this allows them to start working
prior to getting the 30 hours
of
training
they still have to keep they have to
have i believe nine hours to get in the
war
and
they also the persons that we approve by
this
still need to maintain
all of the continuing education
requirements and they would need to get
the educational requirements
no smiling please
okay uh we have a motion do we have a
second
from the subcommittee
i'll second it
thank you representative o'brien so
uh
representative i'll call the role of the
subcommittee representative
font no
yes
uh
representative judy are you here
no vote from him representative mcguire
yes he's giving you a thumbs up
mr representative here he's here
yes
oh and do we have because i do we see a
thumbnail
how do you vote representative judy
we we
okay
no consonants in we okay
uh representative mcguire yes
uh representative o'brien
yes
and the chair votes yes so it's uh
i vote to the um
recommend to the full committee with the
wording of uh to repeat the maguire
broda wording
and the additional phrase as prompted by
representative o'brien and scientech to
put in closely related or closely
related activity
and with that i think we are adjourned
we are adjourned
thank you people
and
now moving on to the posted
executive session of the full committee
so
my script
as chair of the house edna committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the soviet 19 pandemic and in accordance
with how she was 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 personal
executive order 20 2004 this public body
is authorized to be electronics this is
an executive session on bills referred
to the committee scheduled in the house
calendar
executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaries and listen and
invited participate in this meeting by
the zoo classroom gourmet telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
hcs.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by rule paul
though
we will start by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also state whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting
hmm
allegro
present in the room representative
bailey
present in the committee room
representative fellows
home alone
representative fontenot
i am present at home alone
representative goalie
i am home and my wife is in the other
room
representative wrote it
mr chairman
could members in the committee room
please um
if you are not actively speaking please
mute yourself
we're getting some crosstalk
thank you understood uh might i be
recognized mr chairman
not in the middle of a roll
oh i you are voting okay thank you we're
not voting
we're taking attendance meanwhile back
at the ranch representative grota
i'm here in my office alone
representative judy
i'm here my wife is in india
representative lonzara
home and family members throughout the
house
representative lekis
home and my wife's around representing
the choir oh here in the committee room
representative o'brien
i'm president and i'm home alone in
nashua representative pearson
president in the committee room
representative roy
i am here home alone airfield
out of the truck representative santa
mustafa my president
representative schmidt
i am house sitting at the home of a
friend in portsmouth otherwise alone
representative
i am at my home in pembroke alone
representative schultz i am at my home
and my husband is in the other room
clerk is sitting right here
representative yakubovic
present on top of the garage all alone
coming in
okay he's making his way eagle square
madam chairman we have a full house okay
excellent
glad to see everybody here
representative schmidt you had a
question or comment
thank you so much madam chair uh i do
indeed i got a phone call uh from uh
john williams of the hhs department they
have been listening into the column
equally in the last half hour
and they had several important points to
raise
uh so it would be very helpful the
process i believe
so if either john williams could be
allowed into their concerns and their
contribution and what they would like to
contribute to the discussions
thank you
this is an executive session and i don't
necessarily it's not a public hearing
uh i don't know about you but i've heard
from a lot of people
on all of our bills and i'm not sure
this is about the subcommittee i see
melissa clement has her hand right she's
the staffer at hhs
she she's one of the people who would
certainly be uh like like to speak and
the concern that they raised with me in
the con conversation i just had with
them definitely should be part of our
deliberations
uh when we get to a section where
they're relevant we might consider it or
you can relay their concerns
thank you very much madam chair
at the moment we are going to be going
through
uh
the plan for today is to do four
bills fills 114 42 and 57 which we
should be able to completely expect
then we are going to start on senate
bill 133
going section by section except
that we're going to do the ones that had
unanimous or near unanimous
subcommittee recommendations first we
will save the debates for the end
because ms smarling is going to have to
stitch together
a fairly substantial amendment
from all the pieces that get amended
so
yes representative schuett i'll
recognize you when i finish
okay so the plan is to do like i said
these these three bills that we should
be able to complete with full
recommendations
then start in on 133
easy stuff first
and yes representative schuman please
thank you
i apologize madam chair i thought i
thought you were
uh ending
your summary uh
in order to um
make something very simple i think
happened you had graciously extended
uh a period of time to still consider
senate bill 106 which we actually voted
on on april 27th
i have had
subsequent conversations with
my fire chief and with
fire marshal parisi
and i am fine with letting that report
go ahead
so we've already voted on it so
basically all you have to do is
send the paperwork in so thank you very
much for extending me that courtesy
thank you
uh i appreciate that
uh
ms simmons and miss smarling take that
as
as permission to
let senate bill 106 proceed we've
already voted on
which was the one that was posted and we
need to execute this one
representative you have a motion
i do i move that we uh itl uh senate
bill 114.
is there a
second piercing seconds
would you care to speak to your emotion
i would um
so this is the one that i got started
out in the senate um
related to recreational areas and the
title still reflects that
however they amended it to remove most
of it and it just put some requirements
on training for law enforcement in
general
and i believe you uh madam chair and my
and i also went and looked through
what's on the standards and training
website
and what this bill specifies is
basically already part of the training
so i don't think there's any uh need for
this
and uh so i think we should just i tell
it
thank you thank you
do you just speak to yourself no i agree
with everything you said okay
is there anyone who wishes to discuss
this
i would like oh representatives raised
for him senator
yes um
i have had several discussions about
this bill and
unfortunately
the description of the bill and the
title no longer reflects what
the bill was originally intended for
um there are
although there is training that
occurs
um
there this type of training that's being
referred to in this
piece of legislation
involves
um
a more passive
and um less
confrontational type of approach in
these matters that's not specifically
addressed
from my understanding in police training
however i do understand that this is in
the process of being added through rule
making
is that your understanding
representative mcguire
yes the deplete it is currently in the
schedule
and the police standards and training
council is undergoing rulemaking to
incorporate
this specific training for all law
enforcement officers in their rules
so i just wanted to be i just wanted one
to understand that the training that is
referred to in this bill is not
currently
in the training this is something that
would be added in rules
it is currently in their schedule and
the first lesson starts in august
thank
you thank you i saw in if i could
make a comment representative
yeah i looked through what's in
standards and training and the language
that's already there
you're correct it's not quite the same
as what's in the bill
but there is um existing you know
certain types of diversity training and
also um
in the use of force
training um you know trying to
de-escalate situations so there's some
training like this but i think uh
you know making it more explicit and
cleaning up through rulemaking hopefully
will make it better thank you
please represent brodie
yes i'm sorry i'm going to give give my
time to representative schultz thank you
madam chair i did have my hand up um
uh
i actually helped write the original
bill
and as i understand it
um
the concerns
from
the bill authors
and the original intent of the bill is
still something in my opinion that needs
work
i would prefer
retaining the bill to go to the original
intent
which is simply to make sure
that those professions and directly
under
the office of i'm going to get the
acronym wrong please forgive me natural
reason cultural and natural resources
um
that would be responsible for
peacekeeping
in our state parks that is separate from
other law enforcement
um not fish and game
i believe
um
i don't think their title is police off
uh
officers or
it may be
peacekeepers but the original intent of
this bill was simply to
make sure that the governor's
leak commission recommendations on
training which do
include upgrades to the existing
training
would
be
available to the staff
that as i understand it aren't currently
included
in this type of training
uh
the senate amendment and the version we
got from the senate
um
i would support but
that
negates the original intent of the bill
anyway really i mean it's related enough
that it wouldn't be considered a
non-germane
amendment per se
but um
i was hoping that to make a motion to
retain the bill so that we could work on
making sure that the original intent
if it needed to be written into law to
include these sorts of trainings for
those specific
positions
to keep the peace
in our state parks to some degree
other points could be made that
law enforcement also
can be called to various state parks etc
that's still going to be true no matter
but there are some
positions under the department of
cultural natural resources that would
benefit from
the police academy specific
de-escalation
and diversity inclusion trainings that
currently do not receive it as i
understand it
um
there's my points
yes thank you i'm afraid that that
amending the bill to that would be would
be considered non-tremaine since the
senate stripped out all reference to
anything except
these standards
anyway representative ryan
thank you madam chairman um
coming from where i came before as uh my
time is a couple of times is by share
transportation i would agree with
uh representative leckus something like
that was so poorly constructed torn
apart by the senate i probably would
have came up with an itl recommendation
as well too
but then again i look at the times that
we are living in particularly today
and this is a very timely
subject that i think is worthy of this
committee to spend the time
to try to address
uh for what i am led to believe
that the governor is looking at this
also and with the governor looking at
this i think the governor would be a
fine partner of this particular
committee to take this timely subject
and
i think we would do the public good to
uh
retain it and try to work on it if after
the end of retaining is we cannot come
to a consensus or an agreement with the
senate i think we all know what's going
to happen next but that doesn't stop us
from our responsibility of giving a good
college try on this
so therefore again uh regrettably i'm
going to go against the grain of my own
personal old uh
vice chairman status of itl in this but
i think again it's timely and prudent
and it needs work and i'm willing to
retain the bill thank you madam chair
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and
i have a few brief comments uh first
comment being i'm a little disappointed
that ols didn't do their homework when
they printed the amended analysis
because that title does not fit what the
bill was amended to
second i would like to make the comment
that
i agree if this is already being worked
on and placed into rules um
that it is probably not a bad thing to
itl this
my concern with
edna
retaining this into our committee
i truly believe that
the work on this bill should be done in
criminal justice and public safety
committee i truly believe this is where
this bill is
should be placed in wedles language
belongs uh for review
um
i don't see retaining
a bill with this language in it to work
on something that's non-germane
if we it'll this uh the sponsors are
still able to bring back what they
really wanted in place again next year
where it can be worked on and hopefully
be sent to the proper committee
so i would just ask that the committee
think about that when voting thank you
thank you
that's a very good point
it's only marginally related to edna
and as it was originally written it was
not at all
uh thank you madam chair i understand uh
representative o'brien's uh
concerns about continuing to work on it
but i agree with representative goalie
the other thing is i don't know what the
timing is going to be on
the rule making being complete and going
through jellicar and how that would line
up with
you know by the time that's done would
there be time for the committee to work
on it as a retained bill so
yeah i agree i'd suggest letting that go
forward and if um
you know people aren't satisfied with
what they do then a new bill could be
brought in and i agree it should people
should go to criminal justice in that
case thank you
okay representative
thank you madam chair
my only concern is if we do itl this
uh then we're basically ruling out using
this language
or something
very much like it uh in a new bill next
year
if it's discovered by administrative
rules that
uh rsa is needed
so i'll put that forward
[Music]
a valid point but i would say that since
the title is no longer relevant
and the concerns are related to issues
other than what police standards and
training does
any new bill would not be
considered identical
you think just because the fact that the
title is inconsistent that
that would allow the language of the
actual bill to be able to go forward
well the
i think that it was the sections that
the senate took out that need
consideration not what's in the police
standards and training so much
and so yes i think it's
if there's a question about a bill being
identical i'll certainly support
bringing it in because this is not what
was written in running for sure thank
you yes i i certainly agree that
the title and the amended analysis do
not agree with the language that's
currently there like i said my my
concern is that we put are putting that
language for police standards and
training in jeopardy if we kill this
i don't believe that would be the case
thank you speaker's office anyways yes
we will make sure to mention that
uh representative fellows
thank you madam chair um having worked
for the state for 30 years i know that
situations can develop in
any any state agency people people can
walk into an agency and they're having a
mental crisis or they're just angry
about something
and that
maybe
it might be
worth considering considering that
all state employees or state employees
from many different agencies could
benefit from
de-escalation
and
[Music]
techniques for dealing with people that
are
just being difficult or having a mental
crisis and so
i think this is
an important area of concern
but that kind of training um
and to get it to everybody who could
benefit from it from it doesn't isn't
really an
issue that me needs to be in statute it
needs to be it could be in rules but
maybe
it's just more important to talk to
the governor about
funding that kind of training and making
it available to many state workers
thank you thank you representative
goalie
i can't raise my hand
thank you madam chair and i just wanted
to address uh representative schuett's
concerns about this language uh if we
itl at coming back
this language passed the senate so it
could come back through the senate side
had no problem
representative
thank you madam chair i think the uh
intent of the of this bill and this
language
is uh based on the governor's um
council lilliac commission and i think
what representative schultz was
referring to are there are
um
employees within the
um recreation and natural resource and
recreation commission commission
that fall under this
it's meant to cover these individuals
that are not part of the
police academy police
training now
so
there are a few individuals in that
service in that commission in that
commission
that are better city employees and i
think the intent was to include them
and also to make sure as i said earlier
that the
training that
the police academy
gives although includes
some of this training now makes the
training more specific
and since i believe all this is going to
be
part of rules
as you confirmed
um
i will support either motion that the
committee makes to either retain or itl
i think that it's covered in rules it
will be
done
we'll just make sure it's going to be
i will mention that the people like park
rangers and so forth are in fact
considered law enforcement
and they do go to the police standards
and training
uh representative roy
thank you madam sharon
um a couple quick points um to
representative fellows i think that was
a that's a good idea but it's a i think
that's more of an human resources
issue versus the de-escalation training
for law enforcement which is um very
specific and involves use of force and
things like that so it's a
totally different
matter but um i believe that this
rather than memorializing this
in statute this is definitely something
more for rules
um
you know the
the rules are meant to be changed and
adjusted as times change and techniques
change and necessarily um
but not necessarily in um
in statute for all time to be changed
and changed again so i i think that the
proper route is tight elvis
let the rule making process go forward
and should that not be adequate then we
can revisit a legislative solution but
right now i think we should just go with
the natural course which would be the
rule making thank you
thank you anyone else wish to speak on
senate bill 114
all right i don't see any hands
so the motion is itl made by
representative black is seconded by
pearson
representative roy
yes
the clerk votes a cautious yes
uh representative pearson yes
representative yakovich
yes he's now in the room by the way
representative lekkis yes
representative
yes
representative bailey yes
representative lonzaro
yes
representative santo mustafa
representative goldie
yes
representative show it
representative judy
louie
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
no
representative fellows
yes
representative
front no
yes
representative grota
representative of bryant
now
the chair
yes
so it looks like 17 to 2.
okay
uh
representative schultz or o'brien do you
either of you object to consent
and
i don't
i madam chair i do not object to consent
okay representative schultz or will you
be writing a minority report
um
if i had objected i would have said
something sorry i was across the room i
apologize
okay
so in that case we'll put it in consent
and i will ask
uh representative blechus to mention
that the topic that was deleted by the
senate and so was no longer relevant to
this bill
should be considered by the
criminal justice committee next year
okay i'll do that
because it's not our
what they left us of this bill was not
really worth considering
one thing i wanted to bring to the
committee is that the senate amendment
has so far amended one of our bills
house bill 283 wentworth cheswell day
they moved the one day celebration from
2021 to 2022
and i'm going to recommend the house
concur with that
if there's any objections
uh let me know
but i think we will just go with that
hello
yes representative
yes i i did uh i was present
uh or i don't know attending remotely
the senate uh executive session on that
bill
and um
the chair of the senate committee
graciously
drafted the amendment to
enable the celebrations to go forward
next year so i wholeheartedly agree and
hope that the rest of the committee
agrees to concur thank you
okay
i think
this guy chesmar i think he needs more
play but that's going to be another
topic for another day well as i told
representative cahill when he was
talking emailing me about it
the town of newmarket is free not only
to have their annual celebration
of mr chaswell they're also free to
petition the governor every single year
for such an announcement
and
one thing this committee has found is
that if
your organization is getting together
and petitioning the governor every year
you remain more involved than if you get
it put into statute and everybody
in the interest pays out
you know the first of may was national
rhinoceros day
no i did not know that it was true the
first of may was national rhinoceros day
[Laughter]
with you is star wars day
even better okay we will enjoy star wars
today
may the force be with us all
thank you you as well
also representative scitec
wmur did in fact announce
the changes that the senate made to the
bill
on a news broadcast
thank you okay he's getting plenty of
attention i'm glad to hear that yes
i think he i think he should be uh this
is certainly somebody that is a uh a
statewide hero and not just limited to a
town so i tend to agree with
representative scitec that in the future
i'd like to see mr cheswell
taught more and learned about more
because he certainly had an amazing life
very true
all right
moving right along
on on senate bill 42 representative
allegra the promotion yes um i moved to
amend senate bill 42
as described in
amendment 1281 h
okay this one was sent out this morning
if you haven't seen it previously
is there a second
yeah
is that uh
thoroughly study
to put it in context
senate bill 42 was aimed at expanding
uh protections against conflict of
interest
and it spoke in
rsa
95 uh colon one it extended that to
services
uh and my recollection is that this
committee
uh there was little disagreement about
whether that was needed
but there was question about the levels
of um the dollar levels that were
discussed or that were in the in the
bill
uh
the last time it was changed was back in
the 1970s the levels were 200 for both
goods and services
so this amendment raises those levels
i'm sorry
back to the 70s the the dollar level was
200 goods
and uh
200 in services was added later
and this amendment uh specifies for
services
a term of one year
and raises the level of each goods and
services from two hundred to one
thousand dollars
thank you representative
thank you madam chair i want to thank uh
representative allegro for bringing this
amendment forward in addressing the
concerns i had at the public hearing
very good representative
we were we were given the assignment to
check our towns to see what their policy
was and salem has no policy apart from
the rsa
thank you representative roy
thank you
maybe someone could point me in the
right direction is public official
defined somewhere else in the statute i
only have the amendment in front of me
it's defined as a person holding a
public office
and yes this is
uh in 95 colon one which is the
deals with public officers and employees
so a public office would be an elected
official versus an employed official
[Music]
yes
so this bill did not include
employees
okay thank you
any other questions or comments
i'll say that i spoke to my
my selectmen as well
and she told me that well they don't
really have a policy but they try to
keep it open and go off for
out for bid on anything that involves
the
selectmen or other official elected
officials
so i think having a little more clarity
doesn't hurt
all right representative fellows
thank you madam chair um i collected
information about two towns in my area
they both have about 2 000 people in
their population and both of them
do what they do is they have a
set limit below which the department
supervisor can
make his own decisions and one of the
limits was twenty five thousand dollars
so
um
in both cases they really weren't paying
any attention to this
statute
and neither of them had any sort of
policy to deal with this either i
my personal opinion is that
the
municipalities or the entity
should have a policy that is made public
but that's not for us to deal with that
would be something i think it's mostly
an issue for for municipalities and
really
um
somebody
that's it's not for our committee that
would be for county and municipal to
look into that
so i support the amendment because it
makes it better than it is it just
doesn't
it doesn't um
still doesn't address the problem
okay
thank you madam chair
i had a question in response to your
call for questions
so the public official question
represented roy raised so i'm
my question is
uh the police chief uh the fire chief
uh the town manager and so forth uh city
manager those
are they
i think those are public officials but
they are
they are also town employees of city
employees
um
but in most cases anyway they are not
elective
um and so um does that fit into the
definition that we've been discussing
i believe so the um
yeah i think so rsa 95 talks about um
public officials barred from insurance
dealings are from private dealings
it's in this it's in
title six which is public officers and
employees
and uh
i think it's it's
just for reflection
okay thank you
thank you
representative roy you had another
comment
yes um yeah i just wanted to piggyback
on that again i am concerned that it
doesn't address employees because some
of the
big decision makers who would uh make
decisions on contracts and things of
this nature aren't necessarily elected
and um last term i had brought forth the
bill because i discovered that
uh many towns were were doing a
contracts with heat
heating oil and propane suppliers
whereby if the
town agreed to their bid they would give
10 percent off to all town employees on
their home heating oil
which is so unethical um
and i don't know if this is going to do
anything to address that but i i really
think that if we have the opportunity we
should we should make this as tight as
possible
that's all
one one comment if i may on that yes
representative
um yeah we heard that bill last year in
minnesota county and that's actually the
committee it would belong in i think
rather than ours i don't remember now
exactly what happened to it but uh
um
you know but would it i agree that it's
an issue the heating oil when i heard
that was ridiculous but uh it wouldn't
be for our committee i don't think
yes and i will i will mention that after
the hearing
i was tasked with invest talking to
municipal and county
and the chair and the vice chair both
said
there's no problem with senate bill 42
and it addresses a real concern so
i i'm going to support the uh solution
with amendments
of course yes thank you any other
comments concerns questions
not seeing any
the clerk will call the role on the
amendment 1281 h
representative roy
yes
i think i heard he asks
yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes represent lanzaro
yes
representative gold
representative show it
yes
representative judy
representative schmidt
yes representative schultz yes
representative fellows
yes
represent representative fontenot
representative grota
yes representative o'brien
yes
the chair yes
the amendment is adopted 19-0
i move that we uh vote multipass as
amended on sb42
second
all right
second employee
goalie on
what to pass with the amendment there's
an allegiance
i don't think it's necessary to add
anything thank you okay representative
goalie
i think we've said enough
all right is there anyone else who
disagrees with representative goalie
wishes to speak further
yeah
represent this court votes yes
representative pearson yes
representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative monzaro
yes
representative
yes representative goalie
yes
representative
representative judy
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz yes
representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
the chair yes
it is 19 00. any objection to consent
madam chair i believe uh representative
fontenot voted without having his
his uh camera on and that makes his vote
questionable under our rules so if you
would visualize there for us there he is
okay yes he's voting yes again
all right thank you representative
schmidt for keeping us on track
you're welcome
[Music]
all right
senate bill 57
and representative lucas you have a
question
i may have the numbers wrong this one
was um
okay
yes okay this is the uh my motion is uh
ought to
is pass a second
second
thank you
all right representative lekis do you
care to speak to your motion
i do thank you um
this is a bill that permitted uh
pharmacy technicians to um
remotely do certain administrative type
operations related to uh
um
to handling uh prescriptions
and the you know we heard from the
representative from pillpack which is
uh has been doing that for a while under
the uh emergency orders and it just
expands it so pharmacy technicians can
do
what are essentially administrative work
and i don't see any reason why they
shouldn't be able to do that they're
under the supervision of licensed
pharmacists and um
they don't actually handle the drugs
themselves doing this so um i think we
should uh
vote this ought to pass and uh
and make it easier for businesses to
provide people with their meds at a
a reasonable a little better price
anyway
thank you
representative
thank you mem chair this bill
facilitates the continuous continuation
of remote work by these technicians
and um has been supported by
um
the board of pharmacy um i think it's
fine
thank you does anyone else wish to
comment
right
[Music]
yes
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes
represent representative lonzara
yes
representative sanchez
yes representative
yes
representative
i'm not confident that it will
positively affect drug prices but
hopefully expedite i vote yes
a representative judy
representative schmidt
yes
representative
representative fellows
yes representative fontenot
yes
representative grota
representative o'brien
yes
and the chair
yes and even if all it does is make
better working conditions for a few
people one in favor
agree
19-0
okay 19-0 does anyone object to consent
all right
that's the easy part
okay
and i move ought to pass on senate bill
and we will be going through
section by section to develop an
amendment that is no doubt going to be
needed
i'm sorry madam chair are you asking us
to vote on the entire bill
no
no we're going to be vote
you have to have an ought to pass motion
in order to consider amendments and i am
making that notion
i i just have a question i maybe i
misunderstood i thought we were going to
take up 106.
we've already done one of six we i was
just holding on to it and not moving it
forward but we voted oh
oh okay sorry
no biggie
i'll second
thank you all right
can i just ask a question how
logistically i don't understand how this
works if we vote
to um let's say we vote ought to pass on
house bill 133 then how is it that our
amendments are going to be considered or
are we going to have this as part of the
discussion well okay we are going to
consider each section separately
and take
what is probably a straw poll but a vote
of the full committee on each section
whether to i t or to pass in which case
we'll leave it in the bill
ought to pass with amendment in which
case we will have the words we want even
if we it is not an official amendment
or itl in which case we will remove it
for 133
we will get as far into the bill as we
can today
smarling will be stitching all the
pieces together to make a complete
amendment if we get through every
section then we will have a final
amendment that we will be able to vote
on
next
time we meet
and
uh but we will not vote on the entire
bill
today because we don't have a finished
amendment
is that clear
he is
i'm new to this but is this
is this standard procedure
no standard procedure have you have one
topic on a bill right we don't do
omnibus we don't do omnibus very often
it's similar to what the finance
committee does on house bill 2.
but no it's not standard procedure we're
working it out as we go because we
normally do not get
on the buses of this extent
okay
there we go representative schuett thank
you madam chair um may i request um
a five minute turn break before we start
on this i assume it will take a little
while
uh
sure we will resume at 11 30
and i intend to take a lunch break
because i have a meeting with the
speaker at 12 30 so we will break from
12 30 to 1 30.
i expect the first few sections we take
up will be the ones that had unanimous
recommendations in some committee
so they should be easy
representative goalie
just uh briefly um because maybe with
your meeting with the speaker unless you
already have an answer this could be
addressed as to
majority and minority reports on this
bill where there's 13 parts there could
be numerous minority reports on
different sections
i'm just wondering how they're going to
address that in the calendar and
[Music]
i'll bring it up but without
any recommendation i would say there
would be one minority report
which would for example
which would have a different amendment
addressing different segments which
would address the different sections
uh i'll conf i'll confirm that but i
think there's only one minority report
allowed
okay because it i mean there's 13
sections of this bill there could be
three different sections that three
individuals are opposed to
um who would want a minority report just
on that section and that's just my
concern
well i'll manage the minority reports
from the republicans you can manage the
minority from the democrats okay
representative roy you have a comment
uh yes thank you
just to be clear today is kind of uh
hybrid it's a it's a
work session slash executive
and i i i need to we're not going to
take any official votes today as we have
no official amendments
is that correct because um i have to i
have to bug out about quarter of two to
pick up my son for his driver's test
today
well i certainly hope that uh we will be
be through with all the important
controversial amendments by then but
one never knows
and i apologize but it was scheduled
quite a while ago so
that's fine we'll do what we can
yeah i also need to leave um
a little after 11 30 i'll be bad but
i'll be able to be on in the car i've
got to take my wife to a medical thing
and i'll have to wait outside anyway so
are we doing the amendment
for each amendment one at a time here or
i mean is this just all scrolls
we don't have any official amendments on
any of the sections
so you could call it a straw poll if you
like okay so i'm not going to be writing
minute five minute break
[Music]
zooming at 11 30.
we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to coordinate this
better with the rest of the republicans
[Laughter]
and can you mute the room
so
back
on section one
what's your emotion
what's the pass
emotional 2000 second one
second
clarification could we at least
um call out the title for each section
sure
section one is regarding licensing
places of assembly
and we have a second i just i just yes
sir representative sanchez
okay i will vote in favor of this
amendment
i mean up this part of this section of
house bill
as it was supported by the fire marshal
thank you
representative
yakubovich do you care to speak to your
motion
[Music]
i i can't hear the microphone
yeah uh places of assembly can be
allowed now by more state agents
agencies and municipal agencies so i
like this section
thank you
representative
does anyone else wish to speak to
section one
represent the fellows yeah i'm fine with
it
okay
excellent in that case the motion is
about to pass section one and the clerk
will pull the roll on this
is
section one
this is not something i've ever done
before it's broadcast section one sv
okay representative roy
yes
yes representative
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative
yes
representative
yes representative goalie
yes
representative show it
you can't see her
she's not you can't see her
okay
uh representative judy
that a week
yes
uh representative schmidt
representative schultz
welcome back
representative fellows
yes
representative
representative broda
representative brody you're there
somewhere
representative o'brien
yes
uh
normally we don't go back over but
because of the bump in the road here
let's do that
uh i'll check with representative
are you back yet
no not yet uh representative schultz
no representative broda
okay uh the chair yes
looks like 16
to zero
all right and since representative
already expressed her uh
her support
section one will remain in any amendment
that we have
all right
on section three representative
i'll make a motion about section three
oh i'm sorry
yeah okay i'm going mostly
board of nursing yes um and make a
motion of what to pass of section three
okay is there a second
i second
fellows okay this is regarding the
uh relevancy hearings of the new
hampshire board of nursing
prepare to speak to your motion
representative
yes
this allows public members to be on the
same level as everybody else who's
appointed to the board and i i welcome
that
representative do you wish to speak to
your second
um
just just to add that it lets them be
the chair which really doesn't give them
any great privilege more just of a
responsibility to keep the
moving the meeting moving along in
proper
format anyone else wish to speak on
section three
all right seeing none the clerk can call
the role representative roy
oh yes okay great thank you
the clerk votes yes representative
pearce yes
representative jacob
yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes
representative lonzaro
yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes
representative
that's apparently not returned
represented judy
representative schmidt
yes representative schultz
representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot
representative grota
representative o'brien
yes
the chair
madam chair yes
uh represent representative grota lost
her internet connection so she's going
to try phoning in
as soon as she can
okay thank you
and that
both was
and schultz appear to have gotten lost
all right so part four relative
membership of the professional standards
board
echo
um
that's right i make a motion to itl part
four
okay for a second
all right
would you care to speak to your motion
oh sure
this seems to um
restrict the composition of the board of
the school board and
uh more importantly in the other part of
it
uh what they're trying to do is to lift
the term limits because previously
only two full terms could be served but
now they're changing it to two
consecutive terms and they don't see
that we should do that
all right
all right does anyone else wish to speak
to
section four
representative phillips
um thank you madam chair um
i worked at the department of education
so i know
i never worked with this particular
board but i know about it and
well the changes seem reasonable
but i think we didn't
really find out why they want to do them
and i totally understand the part about
consecutive you know to to because that
opens it up for somebody to serve two
consecutive terms
take a
part of the you know a few years off and
come back again that makes sense to me i
don't particularly know why
they want to specify how many
um representatives from higher education
and how many from k-12
and i sent an email to
the committee
staff person
for the two sponsors in the senate
and asking for some more information and
i didn't hear anything back you know i
don't i don't know
if they don't have anything to add or
maybe they are just too
busy you know because it hasn't it's
only been a few working days so i don't
i really don't have any opinion one way
or the other
okay thank you
representative allegra i would just add
to that that's a good point but
unfortunately if they're not responsive
i don't think there's anything we can do
at the present time
does anyone else wish to speak on part
four
there's representative back
and representative schultz
anyone else on part four
seeing none the motion is itl to remove
this section from the bill
and the clerk will call it
representative roy
yes
uh the clerk quotes yes representative
pearson yes representative jacob
yes
yes representative lonzara
yes representative santo despasso yes
representative goalie
no
representative
representative judy
no
representative schmidt
representative
no
representative fellows
yes
representative
no
she's not among the participants i just
checked
yes
question of the chair yes
so
so representative uh
is
not going to be able to vote by
telephone if i understand correctly
um that would be unless her phone has a
camera which for example representative
does he's on and representative sanchez
that is correct
so if she
she calls in on the phone where the
camera will be delighted to have her
vote
right no yeah
as these are unofficial votes um as a
straw poll should it matter or am i off
base
as a matter of protocol i think we
should ask that she
she uh
gives a give us her photo but she's
still not there so it doesn't matter on
this particular one
what was the vote
seven eleven to seven
all right well that one was surprisingly
uh controversial
okay
represented on section five which is
the audiology and speech language
pathology compact the occupational
therapy licensure contact that one is
representative roy
i went to your subcommittee so do you
have a motion
i do uh i move um
ought to pass
there with an amendment
okay
do you wish to speak to your motion
i do thank you please
let's do them let's talk about the
amendment please
yes
the um
the amendment was sent to us
after hearing the bill the subcommittee
had concerns about
the cost of the membership in the um
compact
and that it didn't somehow trickle ball
to the general fund so
oplc agreed to language that they
submitted to us
that would put them on the hook for any
expenses incurred by the compact and the
subcommittee agreed with that
there's also going to need to be an
amendment
for a drafting error
where we decide which section of the law
that this goes into oplc
would like it to be in the in the speech
pathology section of the law
versus into a general section on
compacts i tended to agree instead of
the subcommittee
but we leave that to the whole committee
to decide because that's kind of a
policy issue going forward with these
contacts
yes he said it very well and i'll just
add that um
i do think it made sense the way that
the gentleman from oplc
explained it is
that people in the various professions
are used to looking at the section of
the licensing
or certification laws that pertain to
their
career
and their license or certification
particularly and so
um
that makes sense then to
keep it in the audiology and speech
pathology
section
of the law and that sounds like a good
point
and maybe that then needs to be added to
other
professions
thank you and i i would like to say that
i agree with that point that the
fact of the compact belongs in or
immediately adjacent to the practice act
for the profession because
that's where it's going to be
relevant
we do not have an official amendment we
do force them
uh yeah i have some uh
language that
i'd like to bring
forward for this
for part five
as well
okay
it's it's um on
part five eight b one and i'll read it
to you so you don't have to look it up
this is quite simple uh it talks about
each member state shall have two
delegates selected by the member state
licensing board the delegates shall be
current members of the licensing board
one shall be an audiologist and one
shall be a speech language pathologist
um a concern that was brought forward
from
that commission from the chairman of
that commission was that they're
they have a hard time finding folks so
his his request was just to add the
sentence if there be no one from the
state licensing board who can fill
either or both positions the board may
select as needed a new hampshire
licensed audiologist or speech language
pathologist to represent it
and that was that was just due to the
fact that they're having a hard time
finding folks to fill positions so it
doesn't really there's no change of
intent in any way it just gives them a
little bit
of an ability to
to go beyond the rigidness of the
requirement if they can find no one to
fill it
okay
thank you madam chair and um
i just still have
uh some issues with these compacts as
they're going forward and as we continue
to increase our participation in them
and how it affects
licensing fees here in the state of new
hampshire
as we get
more people involved into these compacts
and moving around from state to state
i'm not sure how it's going to affect
uh the revenue raised uh
by oplc uh as there are out-of-state
licensees participating uh in the new
hampshire workforce
um and that is my concern i
understand uh representative royce
movement with an amendment
saying oplc will
absorb the costs
but those costs will also be absorbed by
new hampshire licensees for those folks
in the compact i would really like to
see it as those who are participants in
the compact pay a little extra towards
the fees to cover
um
that added expense uh going forward um
and like i said i'm
still a little lenient on jumping in
feet first into these compacts without
seeing the ramifications further on down
the line we've heard
board of nursing already adding uh in
the nursing compact adding staff and i
think this is just going to grow on
compacts as states more states get
involved and it's going to be a
bigger expense to
these boards
thank you
thank you representative schultz
oh i didn't have my hand up but um
i
i have an opinion anyways but go ahead
did you mean
any chance
yes i saw the hands of representative
schuett and roy
but
um
roxanne pearson jumped me got in ahead
of representative schultz who made the
second so i was pulling on her first
oh thank you um that's okay
thank you
okay representative
thank you madam chair um
i do agree with uh putting the bulk of
the
compact material in with the specific
profession but i'm wondering if there
should be
a cross-reference to it in
a compact section of rsas
or perhaps
just a spot on the opc
website that lists
the various professions that are
enclosed in compacts
if that would be something worth doing
okay
i believe that that
the each board each profession each
board has their own
page on the oplc website
and the ones that i've seen with
compacts do mention them
in order to
um for example we were looking at
four examples of compacts and so forth
um you have to look at each of the 55
boards to see if they are in fact in
compacts and i was thinking
like i said perhaps just a simple
listing of
those professions that are involved in
compacts it could possibly influence
someone
if they are someone who
travels between states
uh involved in a profession to see if if
the profession that they
are active in is involved in a compact
easel
[Music]
if you're traveling between states
in any particular profession you're
going to look up that profession
the only people that will be helped by
looking at a list of professions of
contacts is us
because everybody else is going to go
profession by profession
you know the the audiologists don't care
if the nurses have a contact because it
doesn't evolve them in the least
well all right my thought was that for
example we've been trying to
craft these so that they are similar
to the laws pertaining to the compacts
well like i said it would certainly help
us
but i can't see that it would help most
most other people
all right thank you
representative roy
thank you madam jim um
just a couple quick points um with
regard to first representative pearson's
suggested language um
i'm only concerned because it wasn't
brought to the subcommittee so we didn't
really get a chance to hear that or hear
if it would in any way impact
the compact i know the language has to
be very specific as dictated by the
terms of the compact so i would just
want to make sure that that didn't run
afoul of that anyway and if if it
doesn't then i'm fine with it um
secondly to representative goalie's
point um
regarding the cost we heard testimony
and i can't point you if it's in the
statute or in the rules and or the rules
of the compact itself but a fee is
assessed to any out of state
person who applies for a license under
the compact
so that the oplc does get revenue from
out of state people
um
to cover what they would have got if it
was
if if they were handling as for example
a normal new hampshire licensee
[Music]
representative
thank you madam chair and i
i appreciate the uh response from
representative roy but i believe when i
had asked that question uh i
it was explained there was something
they could possibly do
that they weren't doing it uh for all
these all these boards
that's my concern
and my concern is how do you track who's
coming in state uh on a compact license
and who's not i'm not sure they can
really do that and i'd like to hear more
from oklc on that thank you all right
that is a reasonable question
if no one on the committee objects i
will ask mr broderick
from the oplc to address this concern
and i should say representative roda is
with us with photo
mr broderick are you can you speak to us
i i am yes and thank you um
madam chair
so uh
i believe
i'd have to
pull up each one these two compacts
allow the old plc or allow the boards to
assess
um
for out of state like someone coming in
from out of state that's there on a
compact privilege we can just give them
a fee it doesn't say
uh it isn't automatic we will need to
come up with rules uh
for that fee so for these two contacts
we can
recoup that cost
um
i you know i'd have to find the exact
spot in there if you want that but i i
know that exists in these two the pt we
already belong to the physical therapy
board compact that has that same
provision and i believe we're charging a
hundred dollars
for the privilege to practice here in
new hampshire so i
we're recouping money
from them um
the other compacts i would have to check
i think one or two of the earlier
compacts that the state has already
joined um
there was not a provision for that um
uh
but i i would have to double check that
and i just got a message i misspoke it
wasn't it's not a hundred dollars we're
charging 65 dollars for the privileged
practice
for physical therapists
and i believe the price for a license
for physical therapist
is 110 for two years
correct
it's not out of line representative gold
thank you venom chair and just a
question for mr broderick is to
how they track
these individuals i know under the
nursing compact we have travel nurses
coming through this state
on a daily basis
taking jobs for three months four months
six months are they
required to register with the board um
so that they know that they're here or
are they just coming in working and then
leaving
um that the nursing compact uh works a
little bit differently than than these
two compacts in front of you now um
and i'm not super well versed in it but
i think that the nursing compact is a
bit different that
if they
if they're in another state and they get
a compact license they can then go to
any state i'm not sure for nursing
whether we get notified whether they
come into the state or not or this these
two compacts in front of you now
um they do so to work in new hampshire
you need a privilege to practice in new
hampshire which um
so we will have a list of everyone who's
working in new hampshire under these two
contacts
follow up
was the
nursing compact originally structured
like these ones are currently my concern
is that these compacts could go the same
way as the nursing one and we lose track
of these folks
i i don't believe so i um i think the
nursing compact was already always
drafted that way i think it was one of
the first it was that
i think it was the first contact the
occupational licensing compact new
hampshire joined um
and
um
it has not i don't believe it's been
amended
um in that manner
for it to be changed it would the the
statute would have had to have been
amended so it would have come through
your committee um
i believe it was only amended once i'd
have to double check
okay yeah i i was told that these
contacts are based on the physical
therapy
contact which is
considerably newer than the
thank you
um
and i believe
the testimony we heard or i heard in one
of the other subcommittees was that with
regard to the nurses they they don't
just kind of parachute into the state
and work and leave they have to practice
underneath
a hospital or a licensee
organization in order to practice
and
in order for them to do that they have
to get a compact license so that i
believe they are tracked um and because
they can't practice on their own with a
compact license they have to be i guess
sponsored with the word they can't walk
work on their own they have to work
underneath a higher licensee
so that's that's how that's tracked i
believe um and as they said this one's
totally different anyway because it's
tracked in a different level
anyone else have a comment question
thank you mr broderick for that
information
madam chairman can i just ask if
representative pearson has his language
in writing that he could provide to me
or to that i believe
that's from
the chair of hhs
and
he sent it to me as well and i forwarded
it to the entire committee
so
it may be easier if he forwards it again
i would love to send it to you pam thank
you okay excellent
so i'd like to
have a short discussion on the question
of whether the language belongs
in the
practice act for these professions or in
a separate section
and
i will
recommend that we go with putting it
into the practice act and i'd like to
hear any opportunity concerns or
opposition to bad news
representative
yes i'm just wondering if you could
explain what that means
this was founded a typo adopting the
compact was put in two separate places
one into a new statute
and one into the
current statute that defines what
audiologists and hearing care and speech
language pathologists
do in their regulation
and that's
so that we would want to remove one or
the other of them
he said they are duplicates and the
question is which one
and i'm suggesting that we remove it
from the section on the contact
yeah
i think that makes sense the concern of
course is you know for someone that's
not
familiar with new hampshire necessarily
coming in it would make sense to keep
things all together
because we don't want to send them on a
choose your own adventure book here to
try to figure out everything that
they're supposed to be doing this really
should be
all together so that it makes sense to
to keep it together
and and not
have them try to navigate navigate the
rsas to just to simply figure out what
they need to do to work so yes
all right so i agree anyone else
all right then we are
so then the
the question of the
uh
amendment brought in by representative
pearson
is that actually an amendment to the
compact itself or is it the statutes
around the compact
that's a good question i'm not i'm not
entirely sure but here's my concern with
this and this is a concern that i i'm
overall not a big fan of compacts but
and here's an example as to as to why
without this you know if the states
if the state's board for audiologists
can't or can't find anybody
willing to do this
we now are in a compact where we have a
seat at the table and there's no one in
the seat
so
you know that's that's a
that's even you know depending on your
opinion of of the control that you give
up in a compact
now having a seat that's empty
further makes that worse now you're at
the whim of something you're not even
part of so so all this does is it gives
them
the ability to fill this to fill the
chair if they can't find somebody
that's all that does and without that
you know this this was brought forward
by health and human services because
they have a legitimate problem filling
filling things in this world this is a
relatively small
community so
um as far as where that
what that affects i i don't know
statutorily where it has to wiggle in
there per se i mean it was it came over
as being in part 5 8 b1
as an add-on sentence but
um that the intent of that is really i'm
just trying to explain the intent here
with this and
if it has to go
somewhere else
okay that is in fact part of the fun
fact okay
um
i think
that
if
yes
i was thinking
if we did it could we put something in
the language around the compact
where we said that if
if the board is unable to
get people to serve on the compact
commission
the uh
they shall appoint additional board
members as necessary to fill those seats
because that would work
i it seems like you could put something
like that in the in the audiology
or or speech language pathology practice
act but i you know certainly mr
broderick is here also to to he could
weigh in this this would not be this
would give the board the ability to
point someone that is not on the board
right when they can't right
right but on the other hand if the
compact specifies that they be board
members
right
well
i i don't understand why they don't have
people on board willing to serve is it
they just can't get people to serve on
the board
that is i can't answer that that's a
health and human services question yeah
sorry mr broderick do you have any
information for us on this issue
um
sure i i may be able to provide
something so
i think here at oplc i don't think we've
had any trouble having um
board members or commissioners serve as
a member of the combat commission so
we haven't seen that issue here
um
as far as where the language should be
added
i and
so my understanding is that for compacts
to work
each state needs to enact substantively
the same language i'm not sure whether
this would
whether this would basically invalidate
uh new hampshire being able to join
these contacts or not i can um email the
com
the draft is the compact language
um right now and see if i can get back
from them
okay person broda you wish to speak to
us
yes thank you madam chair could we make
it a contingency of the compact but if
we don't have anyone that wants to sit
on the at the table or be on the board
then we can't we won't enter into it
that's an interesting idea
after all if you don't have somebody who
wants to take responsibility for it then
there can't be that much of a need
does that not in in essence allow allow
a board to protest themselves out of a
compact
by simply refusing to put someone at the
if they can't fill seats that doesn't
pull us out of the contact that would
require a separate statutory action
no i'm sorry what i meant was if we
don't have someone who's willing to be
part of if we know ahead of time one of
the commitments of joining this compact
would be and i think that this is uh
this should be with all compacts that
institute one of the requirements to
participate in the contract or to join
the contract compact is to be assured
that we have people who want to
participate
in its structure
interesting point representative
schuettner
yes i guess um
my point is sort of aligned with
representative grota's um
my
was that uh in order to qualify
as a board member on the board in state
it should stated are you able to fulfill
this sort of commitment
before you would
put yourself forward as a nominee for a
board member
interesting representative roy
um
i guess the problem is well well we're
we might be um
looking for a
solution in search of a problem if if
they don't have the board members now
they wouldn't be trying to put forth the
compact and there's no way we can
guarantee somebody in perpetuity is
going to be willing to serve on the
compact so the fact that saying that we
need someone to serve in order to be
part of the compact it it
first of all i don't even think that
language would fly by the the getting
into the compact and second of all it
still would require legislative action
to get us out of the combat so i think
we might be getting a little far afield
into this
yeah if if i can speak
yeah i agree with that i mean and the
other thing is putting a requirement in
something like somebody before they get
appointed to a board has to agree they
can serve i mean that's a nice idea but
it's it's not nothing like that's
enforceable um
you know somebody is going to be
appointed a position and accepts it
presumably they're going to try and do
it but again you can't enforce it
and um
i don't think we can put something in to
cause this to happen conditionally
you know either we decide to do it or we
don't it's my understanding
thanks
thank you it's enforceable if you put it
into the statue
so it is what it is you know and we're
making what we're doing right now is
we're setting policy
and if we don't
and so i just think that should be part
of the policy
okay
representative
yeah um by not enforceable i mean if
somebody says they're going to be
available and they're appointed to a
board and then they don't show up
i mean are we going to find them as a
misdemeanor you know
how would we enforce it that's you could
put things in statute but if there's not
a penalty it's meaningless
right
representative shelves
yes medicare um
i don't know that this is a problem that
needs to be fixed by echoing a previous
statement i don't know that
we even need to worry about it at this
point i mean i think we're trying to
create a problem and then fix it as far
as i'm concerned
and um
i think the way that it would be in
the statutes for this profession are
these technically it's more than one
profession but
one section of the law i think um makes
total sense i think the bigger issues
around compacts
maybe is a bigger worthwhile discussion
um
but
much of the issues that are being raised
i don't know that there are even
problems yet i think
having a bigger conversation on compacts
is maybe something we should do
but um
i i'm supportive of it
if the profession
asks for the compact which in this case
they are and as far as i know there
wasn't any opposition
to it in this case and another part of
the bill where we'll get to a section
where there's a lot of disagreement
between one section of the profession
and another section of the profession
and i think maybe those are instances
where we shouldn't have a compact but in
this case it seems to be unanimous
good point representative roy
thank you
just again as far as the board
memberships and stuff i'm not even sure
that that's that's jermaine and before
us because i mean what are we going to
do
um amend so that every single board we'd
have to amend how many statutes to put
that in there that they were required to
be served on compacts and such um i
think that's we're just getting really
far like i said a field on this one
circling back around just a reminder
that all of this all this sentence does
is that it says that if
if um they can't find someone to sit on
the board that they can go are not on
the board on the compact that they can
go beyond their board of directors to
appoint someone this just enables them
to fit to fill the seat and that's it
period there's no other
there's no other anything else with it
that that's all that's all that that's
saying and like i said it was brought
forth by helmand health and human
services because
they are understanding that this is a
problem that they are going to
potentially have so
okay it doesn't it doesn't restrict
anything else in any way
mr broderick do you have an answer for
us
i i do thank you i heard back from the
um gentleman at the council of state
governments that uh had
uh
that in their the group that put this
compact together and they generally um
they they've created all the compacts i
believe um
and he is under the opinion that this
would invalidate new hampshire's ability
to join that is a material material
change to the terms of the compact
um and i i did just hear that the and
i'd have to find this in the statutory
language in front of the compact
commission that's put together of these
may be able to
draft up rules um
saying who could be appointed if there
is no board member available
okay thank you that would take care of
the issue if it
it's more impor more useful to take care
of it if it arises
boy this sounds like federalism and
state uh state rights all over again i'm
seeing red here that this compact is
unwilling to make such a reasonable uh
kind of accommodation
uh i sure hope they can
it's that's
you know we're not this is not a major
change it's a reasonable thing and
all right i've had my cancer
okay represent blackest did you get your
point made
uh
uh mr broderick mainly answered my
question and to representative scitec i
as i understand it for the language the
process would be
i mean they couldn't just answer that to
him and agree to make the change the
commission that if we join we'd be part
of
would meet and would be able to set or
change the rules so
they may very well be willing to make
the accommodation but there's a process
they'd have to go through to do it
okay thank you representative goalie
thank you madam chair
and just to represent a psychic's point
that's why i have issues with jumping in
feet first into these compacts
i think we should wait and let them play
out a little while longer before we get
it thank you
okay
interesting
anyone else have something down
okay so
the motion is to
adopt
section
with the change that we delete this one
of the duplicate sections
on the compact language
namely the section that
is not in the speech-language
pathologists and audiologists practice
act
we add the amendment with the language
that the
board oplc will cover any costs incurred
in the comments
uh
ms marling is that clear enough for you
to draft the amendment
yes i would i would only add that we'll
also put the occupational therapy
compact act into the occupational
therapy practice act
okay thank you that would
be consistent
all right so does everyone understand
what the uh
what the recommendation is
okay so we're done we're going to the
motion is to adopt section 5 with three
amendments too
uh what
what
uh first took the oklc language to cover
costs and uh leading a duplicate section
what about what uh ms sparling just said
about the exact part of this that's part
of the duplicate section
make sure that that the compact language
is included under the practice act for
both professionals and did mr broderick
have it oh
mr uh representative leck has said that
um
we
there it's not that the compact is
opposed it's that we have to go through
the proper procedure
and we uh are yeah all right
yeah that
um
all right representative you have a
comment
uh question madam chair are are we about
to vote on just
the corrected language that the
subcommittee is putting forward or are
we in fact voting on accepting the
entire
section with that language
uh well since it's not an official
amendment i think
uh yeah well let's do it in two passes
the first one is to correct the section
by making
those changes
namely the cost and the proper statutory
organization
okay everyone clear
yes women i'm sure what you're saying is
representative pearson's proposed
language
cannot be added
it cannot be added directly because it
would affect the compact and we have
heard that the
compact
the writers of the compact think that's
a material change yeah i'm withdrawing
that
okay thank you i just want to make sure
i will be yes thank you
all right
so on the
amendment to
the third
world okay so the analogy
representative schmidt if you would mute
yourself when you're taking calls we'd
appreciate it
or is that not a call oh you did mute
yourself i'm sorry i apologize
i
my mistake
so the analogy to a regular bill is
worth
not the amendment then we'll talk about
the bill as
right okay so this is about whether we
should make those changes to the
to the section before deciding whether
we're going to adopt it
so
okay
all right representative roy
yes
clerk votes yes
representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzaro
yes
representative sanchez
representative
yes
yes representative judy
represent judy are you there
we don't have we don't yes he's he's
waving his hands but he's muted okay so
we've got we got it i say i say yes we
we miss you
okay
um
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz yes
representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot yes
representative
yes
representative o'brien
yes sure yes
so on the amendment
uh
to be drafted it is 1912.
all right so we agree that's what we
should do
for that this section
so representative roy then moves that we
adopt
this section as amended
is there a second
second
seconded by representative schmidt okay
representative roy do you need to is
there anything you need to say at this
point
no i think we covered everything
okay representative schmidt
no we're we're good to go
okay go back to the the amendment was
moved by uh roy and schultz correct okay
just make sure
okay and
this is roy and schmidt right and this
this anyone else wish to speak
representative goalie
thank you madam chair well i did vote
for the amendment i think it
made some needed changes to the uh bill
itself
i will not support
this going into the compact
i think we heard just one minor tweak to
legislation that we want to make here in
new hampshire could nullify us in the
compact and that's one of the issues i
have is we have to go by their rules and
not our rules
and i have issues with uh the way these
compacts are drafted up with some of the
language in there um
and i will just be brief some of the
language that they're allowed to do
purchase and maintain insurance bonds
our employees
accept or contract for services or
personnel including but not limited to
employees of a member state
lease purchase accept appropriate gifts
and donate of otherwise abort own and to
sell convey mortgage pledge lease
exchange abandoned otherwise dispose of
any property real personal index
it gives a lot of authority there and
a lot of these uh words and
things that they can do uh
i look at as dollar signs and aren't
going to be costly um so
i just
am lenient about jumping in on these
with these languages that it has a lot
of
terms that
could cost money and um
um gonna vote no thank you
representative
thank you madam chair um
i'll be voting no also uh taking a cue
from
what uh representative roy actually said
originally and uh representative scitec
that um
if this particular
in-state board is not
quite ready to commit to
membership on the compact
it sounds as though perhaps we're not
ready to jump into this
specific concept so i'll be voting no
right now
hoping that if they care to do this in
the future
maybe it could come back as a single
bill rather than
part of an omnibus
yes
i guess
i i if i i'll vote for this on the
strength that the nursing compact seems
to work so well even though
i
i think i
i'm
this is a hard one to
when in doubt do the right thing and all
right
thank you there are a couple of other
people who wish to speak but i have to
leave
so i'm going to
reassess this meeting until
1 30
and we will resume the debate i hope
everyone has a chance to polish their
speeches and make them uh
brief and convincing because
so we can finish this section
all right
we are in recess until 1 30.
take that
until
1 30. i have one concern
this is you know i know we're not in
session or you know the committee's not
in session right now but one general
concern about what the senate has done
is that you know they get a situation if
someone feels strongly enough opposed to
some section
that the committee as a whole votes to
include
then they're put in a difficult position
of either
letting it go through by voting for the
overall bill as amended or
or voting against the whole bill and if
enough people feel that way and could
end up with the whole bill dead even
though you know the majority would have
approved at least some section so i
don't really appreciate what the senate
has done to us
but
nothing we could do about it at this
point i guess so there's no possibility
for like a committee of conference
no they'd have um
wouldn't you
we passed another version wouldn't that
be
yeah i mean we as a committee though
you know at this point are either going
to be able to we can amend the bill and
include whatever sections
we do but you might not have the same
majority
voting to accept the different sections
and when it comes to vote on the overall
bill as amended we can only
you know as individuals on the committee
we can either vote to
for or against dr pastor's amendment
whatever the committee has done
and you know if there's some point
something in the bill that one that some
of us feel is completely unacceptable
then it would make sense to vote against
the whole bill in which case
um it would go to the floor with a uh
you know and i you know well then that
you know it'd be a match
well the same thing happens when it goes
to the floor some people would vote
against it just because they didn't like
one
section two right but that's an argument
i think an insomnia still so anyway
that's mine back to you ask alicia just
ask alicia she'll tell you
i see her in the car there ask her
she'll square you away
hi lis
uh she she can't talk i just uh dropped
her off for a doctor's visit so that's
why i'm oh i'm sorry anyway i see her
waving her hand at me which was my
purpose in the first place
anyway of course
peter the room's going mute okay we're
at lunch you guys can talk amongst
yourselves but the room's gonna go mute
okay
i'm cool
uh
are we unmuted
it
yes we are
so we are in section five what you pass
with these uh amendments right
all right
they're not acting like they can hear me
we can hear you we can hear you yeah
good i will
reconfirm that we
uh
that there is in fact only one minority
report
and
so that would presumably have a
different amendment
however if on the floor a section was
left in that a substantial number of
people wish to delete
it would be quite straightforward
to divide the question
after the amendment's adopted and
kill that section or try to kill that
section individually
adding a new new section by a floor
amendment might be more difficult
okay that would be worth it
i would say yes it would be more
difficult
okay
so
we're assuming
we were discussing the question of
whether section
5 should pass as
the amendment
and
who wishes to speak at this point
a lot of side conversations after i left
well i haven't said anything yet so if
uh
if no one else wishes to speak i will uh
chime in with my two cents worth
and
probably three or four cents for that
matter knowing me but in any case uh the
reality is that we we are already party
to a number of compacts in the state
uh i think oplc has is involved in four
or five of them principally the nurse
compact and and uh
and and we're participating in a number
of other compacts one of the things that
i think is central and i have not
discussed this with uh other members
other than i did have a conversation
with representative goldie about the
other the replica situation a couple of
days ago but i i raised this point then
and i'll raise it now
that is that this committee
above all others would certainly have
uh heard of
problems with compacts or we would see
bills to withdraw from compacts if
that's what's required uh and point of
fact we don't see anything like that and
i've been on the committee for 15 years
so i think we were having problems with
compacts we would be parties to uh
withdrawal from compacts if legislation
were necessary or we would certainly
have seen objections on the part of
any of the speech pathologists
occupational therapists and audiologists
and mr broderick told us that there had
been no objections
to
the attempt to
join the compacts in question um so i
think that's very important that uh that
we are already party to a number of
compacts a significant number of
compacts and we see mutual aid
situations among
uh firefighters for example uh so that
if they are
combating a situation in their own town
uh they called for mutual aid uh
similarly with the ice storm of a
several years ago
eversource hired
line crews from all over this all over
the area to come and help us out so
mutual aid is uh
is a very common phenomenon and it's
barn raising goes back centuries so this
this is a an
attempt to provide additional resources
to our citizens of our state um and so i
will be supporting this uh this
this portion of the bill
all right thank you representative
and you've you've inspired other people
to speak as well representative fellows
um thank you madam chair i
i would just like to ask the people that
were on the subcommittee
if they heard from any actual
audiologists you know practicing
audiologists or or speech pathologists
because i'm i'm just wondering about
their perspective
i don't and i can't remember back to the
you know when we first heard the heard
that bill i don't remember any testimony
from either of those groups but maybe
i'm just forgetting it so anyone has
it's a good question
i will also mention that mr broderick
came back to me with an email saying
that the boards
do not object to this in fact they
support the compact and they and oplc
has never seen any difficulty in getting
board members to serve on the compact
so the
question
the
the amendment that was brought forward
it doesn't seem to be necessary because
the board members
have in practice been willing to step up
to the compact
uh
but the question was that michael
i'm sorry thank you velvet you do you
have an answer
i'm sorry
i missed the question the question was
did you hear from any audiologist or
anyone objecting to the contract in your
work
that wasn't in our work session
representative it's a question to
representative roy
so exactly he was the chair
representative roy would you uh
can you respond to that
it's gotta be barry addison
does not have his
hello um
anyone on the subcommittee please
correct me if i'm wrong but i don't
recall any live testimony from uh any
individual pathologist however um
i can speak for myself and i'm sure
other members have received emails
from various people in the field that
have said that they are in favor of this
i didn't get any against it
and i had my hand raised because i just
want to address something
earlier representative goalie's concern
about the
broad powers that these contacts seem to
have granted themselves
and that's a legitimate concern and was
also a concern of mine with regard to
getting into mortgages and hiring
employees and purchasing and selling
real property
which was why we insisted that any
expense in the compact be borne by oplc
so
because that would be in statute
the compact would have no ability to
bind us to any kind of an expense beyond
what lplc can afford
um so i i think we've covered our bases
on that and as representative schmidt
said there's other compacts that have
been in existence for quite some time
and i have not heard of any of them
trying to get into the real estate
business
i think that us
as states you know someone very wise
once said that you know
the the states are where these type of
experiments should be happening i forgot
the exact terminology um
and not at the federal government level
mandating you know who's going to
cooperate with whom so i think this is
the perfect thing for us to do
um it's been done before it uses
synergies where one state comes up short
and the taxpayers of that state aren't
able to fill that
we can help and they can help us without
putting additional burden on our
taxpayers i think it's just a good good
idea all around and you know
if down the road we see that it's not
working out well
we can repeal it just like um we do any
other statute but right now i i have not
heard anything
negative about it other than
hypotheses so thank you
okay representative
well i just might want to mention that i
uh spoke at lunch to a trusted adviser
who echoed a lot of what representative
schmidt said and my concerns were put to
rest
excellent representative
uh thank you i agree i was on the
subcommittee um we didn't hear
anything against it we've got an email
and support
um the other thing is i mean the the uh
compact that we have the most experience
with i think and the most uh
you know people involved in it is the
nursing one and um
you know i was concerned about this same
sort of things that represent goalie was
around
they seem to have expansive powers and
borrowing money and all that sort of
thing the experience with the nursing
one is that
the cost of new hampshire is something
like 6 000 a year
and that's more than paid for by the
small fee
which remember correctly is on the order
of 15 or something
charged to each one of the
people under that compact who are going
to operate in new hampshire so there is
the ability
in the nursing one and also in the ones
where we have here
to charge a fee to the people that want
to practice in new hampshire
um using the compact system to offset
the cost so
that and the amendment we added uh you
know made me comfortable with what we're
doing here thanks
mr broberg
uh thank you and um i was just going to
add it to representative fellow's
question um
i i believe i i believe you did receive
some written testimony and support from
some of the associations i'm going back
through my email and it's possible that
that only got sent to the senate edna
committee not the house um i
i would cc'd on them
um so
but to my knowledge we've checked as i
mentioned before with all the
relevant associations the new hampshire
ota association for occupational therapy
they're in support the speech language
pathology association um
is in in support in the
as i mentioned the audiologist there's
actually
at least two organizations that um
that work with audiologists in the state
one is asha and they're in support the
others is the i think it's the new
hampshire audiologist association
they're neutral to in support um they're
a very small organization
um
yeah okay thank you that's good to know
any other
comments questions or discussion
okay no hands up
one final point one final point that
that that i might offer and that is
we certainly have heard from the speech
pathologists which with regards to
uh music therapists
uh when they don't like something
we we uh they're not shy about letting
us know
and uh so the fact that we have not
heard anything a negative about them
from them i should say uh suggests to me
that they uh that they are comfortable
with proceeding if not
uh
interested in promoting it
thank you for that uh
no
okay the motion on the floor is ought to
pass as amended on section 5 the
adoption of the
audiology and speech language pathology
contact in the occupational therapy
compact
yes
representative
representative allegra yes
yes
representative lanzara yes
representative
yes
representative goalie
no
representative
um with hope that i'm proven wrong no
i
understood representative
yes
representative schultz
would you repeat that please
i don't believe she's on the call
okay i don't see her yeah i don't see
your picture
okay representative uh
fellows
um i'm gonna i'm really
can't quite decide which way to go but
i'll vote no
that sounds like no
representative funko
yes representative grota
no
representative o'brien
and the chair
yes
twelve eyes
six nays and one non-voting
could you please could you please repeat
the vote
twelve to six
thank you
i'm glad we took up the easy ones first
okay skipping over six
section seven
authority of oplc for administration
rulemaking and enforcement of
investigations hearings and appeals
there is an amendment
which
you should all have gotten and i will
move that amendment
it doesn't have a number it's a who is a
sec thank you representative goalie
it's um
what section
seven
seven seven you're right
all right
[Music]
what it does is that we added
under the investigation
we said that
when requested by the board
oplc shall invite assign an investigator
who may assist in the investigation
which makes it clear that the board has
the authority and the initiative
and the investigator is essentially an
employee
and
we added
under
roman one we added a new section 1a
that these procedures
listed our sections are supplementary
and shall not supplant or supersede any
procedures expressly set forth in any
board's individual practice act
and that's to deal with the question the
situation that some of the boards
have very
well defined
investigative procedures in their
practice act the board of medicine does
and the board of psychology does for
sure because i've worked on both of them
i believe there are others
on the other hand many of the smaller
boards
don't have anything very specific
and so these
provide a
general policy on how to do
investigations
[Music]
see
moving right along under
uh roman four
the
the office or the boards etcetera may
disclose information in it acquired in
an investigation to law enforcement if
it involves suspected criminal activity
rather than just
share with law enforcement
because we feel that it's only if it is
criminal that law enforcement should be
getting involved
um
each board
under roman 6 each board council or
commission may dismiss a complaint if
the allegations do not
state the claim of professional conduct
so that if there's something that is
not under the control of the board they
can eliminate it
yes
would you repeat that last one again
where it isn't
it's roman 6
in uh
let me see if i can find the line in the
actual bill that it relates to
yeah with page numbers are helpful
because
trying to follow the indents can get a
little strange okay you're right
okay this is on paper on the bill
as abandoned by the senate
it's
page 42
lines
33.
um excuse me lines 30-35
and what was the change
amendment
the amendment uh
it says
instead of saying the board
it says each board council or commission
may dismiss a complaint
it's fairly straightforward thank you
okay
on the next page roman four
we're
deleting the first sentence which says
disciplinary proceedings shall be open
to the public
because we're covering the right to know
and openness further down
where it's more appropriate
romans 7
on line 33 also on page 43
we talk about
non-remedial uh
non-disciplinary remedial actions
and
upon making line 35 upon making an
affirmative finding
the amendment adds
after notice and an opportunity for a
hearing
to ensure that it's not just
uh an accusation it's there's due
process for the uh
person
and at the
on
page 44
after line six which talks about the
non-disciplinary remedial action
we add
a new section eight
which says all proceedings for
non-disciplinary remedial action shall
be exempt from the provisions of 91a
except the board may disclose any final
remedial action that affects the status
of a license
including any non-disciplinary
restrictions imposed
so that you might
whether it's supervision or limitation
of practice or whatever
that could be public but the reasons for
the action or not
down bottom of the page line 31
uh technical change it says the board
may dispose of issues
uh it's the board council or commission
[Music]
romans 6 is deleted
romans 16
ah yes thank you roman 6 is deleted
because it's covered
up above under non-disciplinary sections
yes
so we just need to make sure with roman
6 deleted that roman 7 has now moved to
romans 6.
uh yes thank you that is indeed a
requirement
thank you for your for your
your perfect point yes
all right i feel upstaged
okay on page 46 line four
it talks about the board imposing
sections
uh we corrected that to be sanctions
i think the senate imposed sections on
us here
yeah
you're so correct
and i believe the rest of it is the
section as
the bill has
sent to us
the basic intent of these
was to
clarify things
and make sure that it was
specific that the oplc is not
doing investigations that works do not
support the boards have the initiative
they have the technical decision making
the oplc is just there to help and
provide
administrative support which will be
intent
and i support this
the second was representative goalie you
should speak to it
uh thank you i think uh you explained it
very well well i was not a member of the
subcommittee i sat in on the
subcommittee
um
and listened to it and actually gave
some input and some of these changes
were recommendations that i had stated
and i think we make it clear that the
boards still maintain the authority uh
through the process and that like you
stated oplc is there to assist
uh so i will support this thank you
thank you
anyone else
well i made the motion
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
the
subcommittee agreed in concept
unanimously
before we call the role uh
it does uh did uh ms smarling understand
that we still need that further
correction to romans six
just for the renumbering you mean
representative
yes i i
i think there could be a few um
issues you know where renumbering is is
is needed and that absolutely will
happen okay thank you just
sure
thank you this uh
this amendment is going to be challenged
to your
[Music]
editorial capabilities no question about
it
again madam chair just to clarify
we are now voting just on the amendment
for section 8 correct
section 7
i'm sorry 7 7 sorry
section 8 has different issues
other
comments questions concerns
and i'm sorry section seven and section
seven has to do with the authority of
the
oplc for rule making enforcement is that
what we're just talking about yep
okay all right
questions concerns issues
not seeing or hearing any
the clerk can call the rules
representative roy
yes
uh clerk yes representative pearson yes
the representative jacob
yes
representative
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzaro
yes
representative santo nestasa yes
representative goalie
yes
representative
schuett
yes
representative judy
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
uh representatives fellows
yes
representative fontenot
representative brodak
yes
representative o'brien
and the chair yes it looks like 18
or the amendment
okay in that case i move on to pass with
the amendment
second
don't wish to say anything
representative goalie
no i think we've said it all
[Music]
all right
further discussion questions comments
seeing none the clerk can call the role
on accepting
section
yes
clark votes yes representative pearson
representative
yes
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lunzara
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes representative schuett
yes
representative judy
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative fellows
yes
representative fund now
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien yes
and the chair yeah
the familiar 18 to nothing all right
that section stay as amended
um
there
oh sure
sorry we're uh
he wasn't fully equipped to deal with
another
so moving on to section nine
temporary licensure of certain licensed
nursing assistants
representative umich i believe that's
yours um that is correct thank you
how about section eight
section nine five eight now
we could also do eight
i have submissions oh all right all
right
okay
uh yes so um
who moved
yeah
this is a good section we had a few
minor tweaks i believe in the
subcommittee and
did i just see a an amendment come in
for that
okay so if you would so you're moving
the amendment i'm i'm not sure
and uh
is there a second
oh is
does anybody understand the amendment
well enough
if you don't have a copy it's on the
test
okay so i represent pearson are you
second
this motion
so all right so the motion is yeah to
pass the section with the amendment
we'll talk about it
i don't know
what representative
so
which amendment
we we got an email with it i think this
morning at
looks like
6 52 a.m
from mr broderick
okay so represent pearson
um that's it no i
i'm
so so i don't have the amendment
so i'm like i'm kind of stuck
i'll send it out to everybody um right
now
okay thank you yeah
so
the amendment doesn't have a number it's
draft no no it's yeah
we're um in a lull here when we vote
the next after we get through all these
sections and we come to an agreement
then do we vote on the bill
what's the next step after this we've
learned the bill next step after this is
that we will have an amendment that
includes all of the changes we have
voted on yes
and that will be prepared and we will
vote on that amendment and then on the
bill as amended
that will be a amendment with a number
and so forth
so let's say
well i guess we can deal with that later
i'll i'll wait for my question i'll i'll
continue my questions later when we get
there thank you
yes so man i'm sure if i'm if i'm
looking at this right just to get my
second squared away here the uh this
amendment is the part the the bold part
in
section two part one that's
that's in essence what this is doing yep
it's i i believe a way just it's
describing how they are dealing with the
uh
[Music]
the question of
of how to
make sure that they're qualified
yeah
so
i i have a question i'm looking at the
texas an amendment
there's the bold part is that the only
change or is this all this text in here
in the uh proposed amendment also change
oh i don't know
unless it says it's a new section
only the bolded stuff would be
a change
yeah yes the rest of this is the same
okay so they just included a lot of
stuff that might not need to abandon
exactly that's just for context you can
understand it but the actual change is
only to roman 1 on page 48
lines 30 through 33.
okay and so this is just how they can
transition from this new thing to
actually being licensed as an lna it
looks like correct
okay thank you
so so
i have the amendment but
i have the amendment it's gonna take me
a little while to read it
it's only the wrong section roman one
that makes a difference
okay
the attachment of the email i think it's
just the bold section which is only a
couple of few lines
exactly
um
can i ask a question yes
representative so part nine refers to
essentially expanding the
well expanding the door to those people
who want to serve
oh these are the temporary health
partners
this one is this is it the amendment
that deals with temporary health
partners
no yes
no temporary health partners are defined
and authorized in senate bill 155
right
this
this section gives the people who who
have been temporary health partners
a way to become full-fledged licensed
lnas
okay
all right so this is the one that we
talked about
when people have already started this
process
but may not have completely finished it
based on when they started working
they're sort of
grandfathered in
is that right
no we're not exactly we're saying that
since they qualified as temporary health
partners and actually served as
temporary health partners for more than
100 hours
we're considering that
appropriate training to get the
um lna license
okay and i have a last
question it says here in a purpose thank
you the general court acknowledges the
critical importance of ensuring the
quality accessibility and sustainability
of medicaid services
so are we saying that
this would only apply
to those nursing
facilities that
accept medicaid services
i believe that it was the temporary
health partners were only being hired in
nursing homes
but
this doesn't
that that's just a statement of purpose
this bill or this section deals with how
a temporary nursing
assistant
would become a licensed nursing business
right
but they would have had to work in the
nursing home
yeah
madam chair
yes representative schubert yes i just
wanted to call your attention
representative
hiltz has rejoined us uh i did text her
and she informed me that um her computer
ran a monk and did updates and thank you
representatives
she's here she will be called on the
next roll call
or if she raises her hand
questions comments
i'm sorry
well i'm going to go back to this this
one even though stephen
yes
yes i'm sorry i promise i'll raise my
hand the next time
even though
not all nursing homes except medicaid
so if they're going to use medicaid
services as a purpose
it's either there for a reason or not
and if it's not there for a particular
reason it shouldn't be used
representative broda if you are
concerned about
that issue which i can see is invalid we
can just take the whole statement of
purpose out because that's not really
any action that's just
general introductory verbiage and i'd be
perfectly happy to recommend that we
delete it
please i would like that
okay
sorry
i'm happy with that
is is there any objection on the
wrestling committee to taking out the
statement of purpose
well
thank you uh
the statement of purpose uh
gives
people some kind of information about
the co it provides the context
so i mean it doesn't the only thing
that's being changed here well
it's a separate issue really the
bolder language is the only thing that's
new the statement of purpose is part of
the bill
uh
and it says can amend the section to
take that statement
sure we can we can take it out but then
you have no context for the
change that we want to make
all right we'll have a vote on
making that amendment also
what the clarification to the objection
to the word medicaid
in this is because i don't see it as
being restricted
not all nursing homes except medicaid
agreed and
um
but
nowhere in the part of actionable does
it does it list medicaid as being a
criteria or
to
to do anything
i
regardless of what representative
schmidt said i think that the statement
of purpose to this section is somewhat
irrelevant
and
coming in on page 48 i doubt that it's
going to be
the general introduction of a lot of
people
representative phillips
thank you
um
hold on
i have a
unstable connection so i shut off the
video um i'm i'm not in support of this
either with or with without the
amendment
because i'm concerned that there may be
these temporary
nursing assistants
they
it only requires that they have
worked for a hundred hours and they have
made they may have had only one task for
that whole time for example maybe their
only job was to just feed people help
them eat
and to be an lna the training has about
nine different skills that they're
supposed to master so i'm concerned with
giving them a license when they may have
had no experience at all with those
other tasks that are part of the job
and i also think that the state can help
them out by giving them you know
covering their tuition
to do the classroom part of it and
you know some kind of assessment and
just fill them in on the skills that
they need i mean
i like the idea of giving them the
opportunity
to quickly get
the um
the lna status but i'm just concerned
that um
the of the quality of what will happen
if this if this is the way we go about
it
thank you for your thought now
uh thank you madam j well i i would be
inclined to agree with representative
fellows
if it were not for the statement of
purpose uh being in there i think the
statement of purpose explains
why we're taking this
kind of unusual action to
to license these people that stepped in
and helped
during the pandemic and they and it's
like
it's a one-time uh
kind of a one-time action i think to to
do this because it had to happen prior
to april 1st so
i'm inclined to support it if the
statement of purpose is left in there
thank you madam chairman i i agree with
that senator fontenot purpose gives it
clarification why we're doing it i would
also point out that
you know anyone hiring anyone who's
licensed under this chapter
will have their resume they'll see their
uh you know education and bona fides for
the job
so if they feel like that the
experience they have doesn't qualify
them for the job they're applying for
they're free not to hire them so i i
feel like it's transparent enough that
anyone making a choice to hire someone
that's licensed in this section
will be able to know what they're
getting so i i support the bill
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and i i agree with
representative fellows um as you read
this
it says that the person has worked no
fewer than 100 hours as a temporary
health partner but it doesn't define
what skills they should have done or
what they have worked done for work in
those hundred hours
those hundred hours like she say could
have been just um
taking care of the meals or delivering
meals and making sure these people are
getting breakfast lunch and dinner um
and then if you look further it says
temporary health partner
definition means anyone authorized to
work in a nursing home by emergency
order 42
and required to complete training no
less than eight hours only eight hours
of training and working under the
supervision of an rn aprn or lpn so
those other 92 hours are working doing
no definition of what
that entails um so i do have an issue
with that so i can't support this
okay
thank you madam chair um i just wanted
to respond respectfully to what
representative roy said
that um my
the way i look at it i think that if
somebody applies for a job as an lna
and it says and they show that they have
an lna certification with a you know
number
that
um the employer is going to assume that
they have all the skills that lna's
received training for which may not be
a correct assumption for these people
under this
program the way it's put
okay together
i think we're
diverging from the question of the
amendment
uh
is there is there any further discussion
on the amendment to this
representative
pearson
i guess i guess i have a question in in
reference to that this is all
where it talks about may apply for a
license as a licensed nursing assistant
new hampshire does that
require i believe it does
i didn't hear the question could it be
please
if an a required an exam i believe it
does so if it requires an exam it should
show competency in
whatever area is covered under the exams
any other questions on the amendment
representative fellowes still wishes
well
i i
i don't
in terms of the
either the bill or the amendment that um
these people are not going to take the
exam
why not
it says why would they apply for a
license
it doesn't say that they're that they
they're only being
granted
a board certified approved nursing
assistant course
so they're
they still have to meet the other
requirements of the license
well
do they be given a license as they may
apply for a license well
don't they take the take the exam to be
able to get the certificate from
whomever they took the course from
not necessarily it's impossible
when we did the emt equivalent bill we
covered it there they have to take the
exam and then
so not even in that case not necessarily
they have to take the test
well can we ask can we ask oplc do they
take the exam after they pass the course
or
before they get the license or do they
have to pass take the exam before they
get
the
credit for the course
uh good question
mr brobert can you answer that question
if you're still with us
i'm sorry can you repeat the question
this says that they may apply for a
license the question is do they take the
qualifying exam
do they still take the qualifying exam
in this case
uh
i'm not sure i mean i can get back to
you i'm sorry all right okay thank you
please check on that
representative
representative judy is next i do have a
further question that mr broderick may
need to check on
okay which is
i'm just curious if that exam would
include a practical portion in addition
to written
okay mr broderick you've got a challenge
on that one i can check on that as well
thank you representative judy
yes madam chair
uh
if someone have
someone has a license
and he used to work like in new york or
massachusetts
when he when that person comes here
he have to pass the exam even though
he has some
[Music]
times of work
have experienced
uh it depends on the type of licensed
representative judy some
professions require a
new specific tests others don't
and i don't know the case of nursing
assistants
okay all right thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
let me make sure that i've
got my video on so you're all
able to see me um
so
i've spent considerable amount of time
in nursing home i'm the chairman of the
stratford county delegation so i have
some oversight with regard to the
stratfor county nursing home
uh but also i've had several friends
who've
been in nursing homes where i visited
them on a weekly basis
uh so i've seen this a lot of this and
the reality is
that
well first of all some states don't even
license
nursing assistance
licensed nursing assistants we call them
lnas some states don't even license them
but the these are all tasks that need to
be done
okay and if they don't have nursing uh
lnas
uh
in our nursing homes
uh to feed to to change
uh to
[Music]
do
laundry or whatever
then they have to have
those are services that have to be
provided and if they're not provided by
lnas and they have to be provided by our
ends and in when you have critical
nursing
critical service
shortages which is what the
the purpose statement says that's why
post taking it out
if you don't have
uh those services provided
these nursing homes all have ratio
requirements they don't have enough
people doing the doing the various
different tasks especially
uh rns and so forth and more skilled
positions then they can't operate the
section but the people are there they
need the services and their shortages
critical shortages that's why this is a
temporary measure
to
help get people in and if all they're
doing is feeding people then that's all
they're doing but if there's nobody
doing it then an rn is going to have to
do it
so
this is a pandemic where they have
shortfalls
this is a temporary measure where you
have to you know
this is a dog-eat-dog situation and
these nursing homes are in desperate
need in many cases of staff
so i'm supporting both
the amendment and also the purpose
statement
because
these people are in dire need
thank you representatives
on the shoulders of uh representative
schmidt and scitec for something that
we're just saying
they are critical needs and
uh i feel like we're
as representative scitec said on a
different subject before i feel like
we're debating the federalist papers
here
i also have served in the nursing
nursing homes and performed some of
these tasks myself and i'm not trying to
be facetious or make light lighter
but the truth of the matter is we're
talking about
putting a spoon to someone's mouth we're
uh cleaning their their bottoms
afterwards i don't remember all of the
skills that were listed in one of these
documents but the others that i recall
were helping somebody walk helping
somebody sit helping somebody stand
these don't seem to be
they're critical
but they're not exactly uh
high-level skills that can't be
learned quickly on the jobs
so i'm going to support both the
amendment and the bill
okay thank you representative amen
so
i i agree with representative allegro in
terms of like what some of those skills
are and that they can be learned fairly
quickly i'm just concerned that the
temporary worker who
the only task they ever had was feeding
people doesn't know how to properly help
somebody stand up or to roll them over
in bed because these can be very frail
people and you can you can
do damage if you don't
help them in the correct way
and i don't think it'll take a long time
but i'm just um very concerned about
just broad brushing this
thank you representative roy
thank you um since we're waiting for an
answer from mr broderick i would just
reiterate that and i know representative
fellows didn't agree with me but um i've
done some hiring and firing in my day
and i don't just look at their license
or i look at where they've worked and
their experience in life and on the job
so if i needed a specific task i would
make sure they had experience now other
than just the licensure and the class
to the contrary these people actually
have work experience versus someone who
just took the class who doesn't so
hopefully the test will will uh
alleviate this question but if it
doesn't i would still suggest that the
people with the practical experience uh
actually have a leg up possibly over the
people who just took course
so um and and to reiterate
representative schultz said
um you know desperate times desperate
measures we need people in there to help
these folks
and us saying you know you can't do it
without this course does not make any
difference at all to the elderly person
who needs help bathing and getting fed
um we see this in many professions
across many agencies uh personally i can
speak you know i know the military their
their enlistment criteria goes up and
down based on you know the need of the
service
and sometimes you have to put the need
of the service above what the ideal
and um
it's not ideal but we need these people
and if we can safely put them into into
work um i suggest that we do so
i'd like to make two two quick points
one we are not accepting these people
from the continuing continuing education
requirements
for lnas which do exist
and they will these people may get the
license more quickly but they are
required to maintain their competence
and secondly it is a one-time event
it's only people that have already
served more than 100 hours
even if they only had 99 hours by april
1st they wouldn't have qualified
so we it is a limited batch
representative brother
thank you ma'am chair i just wanted to
um
what you said essentially
is uh
summarizes what i was thinking is that
we shouldn't get this particular clause
of this bill
mixed up with the
clause
in house on senate bill 155 which
is broader than this particular section
of senate bill 133
my comment about the the purpose in and
the medicaid
is that when we refer to
the suspect
sustainability of medical or medicaid
services provided nursing home
what the what it says to me and most
people who would be able to
comprehend
english reading is that this has to do
with the
facilities that
provide medicare so if we just got
medicare medicaid
medicaid medicaid sorry so if we just
say
that you just take that word out because
it is we're not going to limit it to
nursing homes that provide medicaid
where this is for all nursing homes
correct
it's also it's for all employers of
lnas whether they work in a nursing home
that provides medicaid or not
correct
so if we just say
the general court acknowledges the
critical importance of ensuring the
quality accessibility and sustainability
provided in nursing homes and recognizes
the critical storage of licensed nursing
assistants that's all
because i think if we put the word
medicaid in
it will
limit those facilities that provide
medicaid
well
actually represent broda that may have
been the
facilities that hired these temporary
partners
we're only dealing with the people who
have already served as temporary health
partners okay
okay i understand i withdraw my request
thank you
other questions comments
issues
can i um comment madam chairman yes
please i i know that i haven't been in
um you know listen to every word because
i've been running around a little bit
but i don't know if you discussed that
just the
the
grammatical sense of of the paragraph
one that is amended by the the new
language it does i believe that after
i think it should be having demonstrated
okay and then just reading the full sent
it's all one long sentence now i think
that helps
um but persons who have worked no fewer
than 100 hours as temporary health
partners at a licensed nursing home
by april 21st have demonstrated their
work experience during a national and
state public health emergency the
competency to transition to status as a
licensed nursing assistant
it seems like a new sentence needs to
start
there i would be delighted if you would
when putting the final amendment
together you
clean up okay in such a way the
important point is that this shall be
deemed to have taken a board approved
nursing assistant course
right
so yes please uh
i noticed that myself when i read the
amendment that
the grammar was
right and this the sense is is clear
it's so um great i just wanted to
point that out and i see if you had
talked about it
and i'd be happy to
add some words in there
yeah we haven't actually talked about it
but i wouldn't i would agree that the
grant it doesn't appear to be very
dramatic representative font now
yeah i just that thank you madam chair i
just wanted to reiterate you know i
think most know that i am a proponent of
licensing and i just think that the
reason this particular
bill is worthy is because we are
acknowledging that these temporary
health partners stepped up to the plate
during the time that many people retired
early from nursing homes and and took
leaves from their jobs at nursing homes
because they didn't want to be there
during the pandemic and these people
stepped in and did a job that a lot of
other people didn't want to do so i
think that's why we're
kind of
we're stepping aside as some of the
usual
requirements and saying you guys deserve
um
you know
to move forward in this profession if
you so choose
thank you good point
other comments questions
very quickly uh
about the hundred hours being one
particular test i don't think any of
these if you have to work 2 000 hours
and then something specified spectrum of
what you do on that job you could do
just
a 14 gauge romex and never touch
anything else
yeah that's true
the idea the expectation is if you're
there that long you'll uh do a little
bit of everything which i think is
is pretty reasonable
especially
particularly if they're short-handed yes
good point
so
any other comments questions
texting back and forth with
representative schultz uh her computer
is kind of going in and out so when you
get to her to vote if
her computer has died she has her cell
phone ready to cue back in
okay that's very very well prepared of
her upload she's
yeah we may have to wait a few seconds
for her to come back
there we go
thank you madam chair i'm here for now
though
excellent in that case we'll vote um
take a vote on the amendment
the motion is to adopt the amendment
presented on
part nine
and representative roy
yes was the pearson second into that yes
uh representative roy
said yes uh okay clark
representative pearson yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzara
yes
representative stanton esposo yes
uh representative gold
unfortunately you know
representative shui
uh
yes
representative judy
we
representative schmidt
representative schultz
oh he's coming back i vote yes yes
sorry okay representative fellows
no
representative funknow
yes
representative broda yes
representative o'brien
yes
and the chair yes
okay it looks like did did you get my
vote represented scitec i voted yes i
did i did
thank you i'm sick
so we have successfully amended section
9.
madam chair yes
um i have further amendments to this
section the reminder okay i can describe
them representative
dr bulwick has another amount
which is
um
uh it's
it's it's of two parts one
uh which we actually was representative
gaul's idea during the subcommittee
which is to delete change the effective
date to immediately upon passage because
right so that to change the effective
date to on passage okay
and the second one which i also
mentioned during the subcommittee uh
take out the april first
date in
title i section one
because
it's kind of superfluous and it's
unnecessary
the temporary health partners are
already defined as somebody
who falls under the emergency order 42
so while we're still in the middle of
pandemic
on the battlefield like mr clark
described
the pandemic battlefield
we should just simplify this bill and
make it rely on the emergency order 42
being lifted or the pandemic ended
so i'm just suggesting removing april
1st 2021 and i ran it by the sponsor of
this bill and she agreed
that's a great idea right so that you're
saying that the
ah so it's
already covering the emergency order
correct
instead of the date it will say the
ending of the emergency order you don't
even need to because uh temporary health
partners will end up on the end ending
the order being rescinded okay that's
interesting is there a second
second
thank you representative schmidt
i'm sorry i guess i already spoke about
it so that's fine you already spoke
about representative schmidt
i do not
okay
is there any
discussion on
on this additional change
was that further amendment further
amendments
so this this would allow people who
get their 100 hours
in
before the end of the pandemic no matter
when it ends
to apply for this exemption but
only people who have served during the
pandemic okay
correct correct
further comments questions
seeing none
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzaro yes representative santo nastaso
yes
representative goalie
representative short
yes
representative judy
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz yes
representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
and the chair
yes thank you nothing in the further
amendments
matt madam chair
yes
um i need perhaps five to seven minutes
i have to escort my son into the dmv to
sign him up for his written test i'm not
sure what you planned on taking up next
uh
section
section 9 section
we're not going to vote on this we're
going to finish this then 10 and 11 so i
think
if you're only going 15 minutes we'll uh
i don't think it'll be a problem
okay i appreciate it i'll jump back in
when i get back
so the question is
to adopt section 9
i moved to otp section 9 as amended
all right we're incorporating
both amendments
[Music]
okay is there a second
i will
okay represent bailly got in first
okay
do you wish to speak to your option um
we need all the help we can get while
we're in the pandemic
so this will will help us thank you
he said it so well
all right
is there any further discussion
seeing hearing none the motion is to
adopt
section 9
with the amendments
representative roy
she may not be here
he's not here
uh the clerk for t.s representative
peterson
representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzaro
yes
representative santana
yes representative goalie
no
representative
yes
representative judy
we miss you representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz yes
representative fellows
no
representative funknow
yes
representative brody grota
representative o'brien
yes
chair
um
is that 15 to 2 i didn't hear 16 16.
okay that's section nine
section ten
i move to adopt section 10 uh otp i'll
second to that
can you please have a name for this
section
it is relative to the revocation of
licensure for licensed emergency medical
service units and emergency medical
service vehicles services
okay that is moved by
ought to pass by versus
dental village and the second
yeah
this will simplify
licensing issues um
for uh
for ems units
not licensing but any any questions
about the license any violation of the
license
allowing time to answer
something
yeah i mean this is this is uh
this allows for discretion and i think
that uh you know when we we have to be
careful in statute when we use
the word shall in may and
all those things and i think that
this is this is uh this allows for the
commissioner to do their job
questions comments or
concerns
is there a way of making
yes thank you
i guess i i'm not
can somebody get give me a summary of
i don't i really didn't
get this the uh a good
summary of what this
section is about and why we should
why we should support it
okay
[Music]
well i'll give you my interpretation
right now
the
uh commissioner can only
susp
deny an application for suspend or
revocable license
for any
acts or offenses even if they have
already been corrected
or worked
so in this case this allows the
commissioner a less extreme
punishment that is to issue a formal
letter of concern
that will not suspend or revoke the
license
right
is that correct
yeah
yep
like i said it allows for some
discretion here um
within the context and circumstance of
what's going on yeah
representative
sorry um
and represent pearson can correct me but
my take is that another
potential benefit is if the only choice
presented
is no action or take drastic action
such as revoking someone's license
there might be a tendency
to
not take action in situations where
doing something
short of revoking a license would
actually be helpful
and so this might actually contribute to
getting problems resolved
yes but on the other hand
if
they may
then nothing might happen
so i i i understand the issue issue a
letter of concern i agree with that
but i don't agree with the changing of
the word from michelle to may
because then the commissioner may not do
anything and some of these
um
some of these offenses
might be significant
that's correct
representative
uh to speak to representative
pearsons uh or your concern
that's what he can do now
he may say that in the interests of
overall justice i'm just going to look
the other way and who's going to do
anything about it
exactly
yeah i mean
the problem in any of those kind of
things is um
you know if there's some situations
where you'd like to see them
revoke a license and others to
to issue the letter of concern or
something left
i don't know how you can do that without
leaving it to the discretion of the
person making the decision because i
don't see
how we can draw some bright lying in
statute as to
exactly when one is appropriate or the
other is
and yeah there's always the risk when
there's discretion
that somebody's going to make a bad
decision
but
it's kind of as was said that's the way
it is today also there's always pro in
effect it's
prosecutorial discretion
which is there uh you know in this
situation as well as a
you know the d.a or something
like that breaks your heart
so so also too so for those of you that
that may not have looked up the sighting
of this right because it talks about rsa
153 813 153 a13
has that lovely part of statute that we
call knowingly does x
and knowingly
is difficult and just in the nature of
of
having knowingly gives or knowingly
causes or knowingly does
that lends itself to discretion because
you're sometimes you know how do you
definitively come up with knowingly
so this this allows the circumstances in
in the you know the commissioner to
to use their judgment in the question
so it's gonna be an official id school
idea i guess is not good
terry
oh he just knew himself okay
so go ahead
so i mean i'm back
yourself thanks no
but but if you if you if you guys can
understand what i'm what i'm what i'm
saying here you know that the the
section that's referenced involves you
know
knowingly gives their causes to give or
knowing knowingly gives or causes to be
that that lends itself to the need for
discretion and i think that this simple
change just allows that to occur
yeah
there's also i'm okay with it violations
okay represent fellows
yeah i just wanted to say that that that
i
appreciate representative pearson
telling us that because it then it all
makes perfect sense so somebody does
something that they really shouldn't
have done
and this is a whole list of
the possible reactions to that situation
and the new option of
letter of concern that's just like in a
business when you put put a letter you
know a note in somebody's personnel file
or when or when a police officer gives
you a warning for speeding
that goes on the record so if you do it
again you're going to be in big trouble
but it's
not going overboard if it just happens
once
exactly
other comments questions concerns
all right seeing none
the motion is about to pass on part 10
and the
rule
representative roy
is not yeah
the clerk votes yes
representative pearson yes
represent representative jacob
yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative representative bailey yes
representative lanzarra
yes
representative santo destasso yes
representative goalie yes
representative
yes
representative judy
hello
in english when in french representative
schultz yes
representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot
representative broda
yes
representative o'brien
and the chair yes
that's true that's true
all right moving right along to section
11.
representative lucas you have you have
actually an honest to god
full amendment
worry about that um
[Applause]
thinking too much about the prior one
and i don't have the thing
uh section
that's the wrong one 11 is on page 49
and your amendment is number 1260.
and the
yeah hang on i apologize for not being
as organized as i should be
and having the amendments and hands
which madam chair
would miriam have sent us the amendment
is that correct
i it should have been
ms marling if you could perhaps resend
to those
sure
i can uh i can describe the change i
think uh
reasonably uh
easily so the issue was that
part 11 among other things uh changes
um the apprentice from being a licensed
to a certificate
and the changes for the part of the uh
rsas that it specifically is dealing
with there makes that change however
there's also rsa
313-820 which deals with
expiration renewal of licenses
uh just calls them licenses and deals
with them all as a block including um
you know the apprentice what we're now
going to be calling apprentice
certificate and so the amendment just
changes uh
mainly it changes 3 13 20
to um
split it up and deal with the licenses
as licenses and certificates
certificates
so it's not ambiguous as far as the
language goes the other thing it does
is we were bringing in uh the changes
from
senate bill
carol what was it fives house bill 5.75
right house bill 575. so
there was a similar language there which
uh i i'm understanding is carol's
arranged for the senate to remove that
so there wouldn't be
conflicts but when the initial amendment
or the initial uh changes were done it
left out an important part of it so and
that part is in
um
okay on page 50 line 5.
thank you
for being more organized than i am
and um
it changes that where it's within a
licensed school or shop to license
school and or shop
since um
you know we're now permitting them to
receive
some of their training um you know
in one or the other or a part in one and
part in the other so that change allows
that to be there as well
so that's actually the substantive
change and the rest of it is just
cleaning up
you know whether something's called
referred to as a certificate or a
license
i
reviewed house bill 575
and i have worked out the senate an
amendment
that deletes
their section
history that amends
rna 313 824
that's the only part of 575 that
overlaps with this
and so by incorporating the and or here
these the senate will amend house bill
if they choose to pass it
and say that there's their section
a13 a24 does not apply if house bill if
senate bill 133 passes that looked like
the cleanest way to handle it because
the rest of 575
is in different sections than this one
than
senate bill 133
and the
question of the hours is only in house
bill 575 this
senate bill 133
simply says and a program approved by
the board
so the
[Music]
this makes
makes it compatible and as
representative like i said it also
cleans up the reference to a certificate
rather than a license
any other questions comments
representative grota
thank you so
what's the difference between
so if an apprentice
goes through this program
then they attain a certificate correct
no
they get the certificate when they are
going to start working in a
a shop
the if i may all right
or getting getting instructions
they have to have a certificate before
they can act as an apprentice
so they get the certificate first
they get some or all of their training
through the apprenticeship
as part of completing the requirements
for the for them to then apply for a
license
yes this
it specifically says online
page 50 line 4 that the board shall
issue the like apprentice certificate to
any student receiving instruction
so they get that first
right and that way the the place that's
going to take them on as an apprentice
knows that it's it's okay to do so
and and the
and the requirements for being for
having the certificate is going to be
put together by the board and then put
in rule making
no representative it's in the bill on
page 50 line 7 through
13. it's
16 years old pay the fee
and be deemed to be a good professional
character
which
for high school students shouldn't be
too difficult
so basically you're high school student
and you want to be
an esthetician
so you follow these qualifications
and then you go work for an esthetician
and through that you become you get a
license to be an esthetician is that
what you're saying
you have to complete the hours specified
by the board's rules
and you have to take the appropriate
test
getting the training either as an
apprentice or in a school licensed
school
is you know that's just one of the
requirements to get the license
and why do we think that this is a good
idea
the
well for one thing it gives the board
specific authority
to
regulate apprentice
schools of of cosmetology etc in that
are within high schools some high
schools have them including concord high
i believe albert may as well the other
thing
talking about the section as a whole
rather than just the amendment is if you
look on
page 50 lines 21-23
um
it lets them get the apprentice
certificate
without requiring the social security
number the reason that was done
is because of these programs they're in
high schools and there's the for the
federal uh
student privacy laws that said that uh
the school can't demand uh a social
security number so that's why that
change was put in there to actually make
it legit to have uh these programs as
part of vote tech programs in high
schools
meanwhile there's a secondary uh
federal requirement that if you're you
have a professional license that allows
you to work you have to provide your
social security number you can make sure
you're paying troubles
right so i guess the plan process is uh
if someone's at least 16 they're in high
school
they get their apprentice certificate
and um they don't have to provide the
social security number for that
they go through that apprenticeship
program and schooling
within the high school
it doesn't happen within high school but
that's sort of the idea
um and then you know they'll be done
with school they'll turn 18
and then go through the remainder of the
process to apply for an actual license
and then they can work
but kind of give so that way they come
out of high school with uh
you know the ability to to get a job and
do something representative goalie
thank you madam chair um i was part of
this subcommittee and if i remember
correctly
uh the main reasons for these changes
in the apprenticeship programs were
for
some of the high schools that had these
trade programs associated with them
by using the language of a license
they were required to give social
security numbers and
the schools
under
who are not allowed to give out social
security numbers of minors
and
someone can correct me if i'm wrong
so this was the reason why
line 21 was put in 21 through 23 was put
in at the bottom and as well as
changing the wording from license to
apprenticeship to allow these students
to
complete a program while still in school
going forward
thank you
thank you that's that's my understanding
as well
other comments or questions
right seeing numb the motion is to adopt
amendment 1260 to
part 11.
and the third
rule
representative roy
yes
yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
yes representative
yes representative judy
we miss you
representative schmidt
yes
representative
representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot
representative broda
yes
representative o'brien
yes chair yes
and back back to representative lonzara
is are you back representative lonzara
yes sorry about that
okay so it is 19
0 for the adoption of amendment
12 16.
over part twelve
so if you're ready i can make the motion
to
[Music]
we've adopted the amendment so i guess
we need a motion to do otpa on this
correct
and i'll make that motion
a second
and
all right do you just speak to your
passion no i think we've fully uh
discussed this
i agree anyone else
comments questions
this is part 12 manager
now we're still on part 11
to finish
to adopt
represent roy yes
representative
clark votes yes representative pearson
yes representative jacob
yes representative
yes
representative allegra yes
representative bailey yes
representative juan zara
yes
representative
representative goalie
yes
representative
representative judy
i know you're there representative judy
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot
representative broda
yes
representative o'brien
and the chair yes
19-0
okay
that being at the three o'clock
i think we will now take up section
two
and
velvet
my motion to itl section two
okay
do you wish to speak to your motion
um yeah
briefly um i think with compact our
patients will have wider access to
providers to
people
in in the medical field that's why i'd
like to keep the compact thank you okay
representative ryan
thank you madam chair yes also uh
briefly
um
this is different than all the other
compacts we're talking about because
this is one we're already in
this isn't whether or not we should get
into it all the legwork has been done by
previous legislation
all the arguments have been made all the
potential outcomes vetted and a decision
was made to put us into this compact
and although it passed several years ago
it just came into effect last year in
the middle of the pandemic
so any points made so we haven't had to
use it are really
uh not accurate because we haven't had a
chance to use it um
i've we've heard from the state head of
ems we've heard from the
from private
companies
we've heard from the compact itself
all in favor no one against except for
one organization
and i have total respect for that
organization
firefighters as i used to be in law
enforcement i like a brother from
another mother to me and i stand with
them
however i just can't support
withdrawingness at this at this time
based on hypotheticals if i could see
some real harm that would be done
then i would definitely support getting
out of it but at this point
um we have to at least let it all the
work that was done we have to at least
let it
try to work
before we go ahead and pull it out with
absolutely no reason
and that's all i got thank you
questions and comments
represent pearson
sure
a couple things
with uh
with this
one of the things that
that we were we were blessed with was a
tremendous amount of confusion in the
public hearing because there were
things that were said and things that
were brought forward that don't actually
apply so a couple things to to clarify
this is um
this is a compact that is that only has
a use under an emergency scenario this
is not a daily procedural compact okay
so
some of the things that were brought up
that were interesting the whole
dod angle with the spouses of military
folks if you come into the state of new
hampshire as a someone who has your
national registry and you apply to the
bureau of ems you're going to have your
license in a week or less
so it's not a barrier for that at all
the other thing is that because it is an
emergency scenario use only a couple of
interesting things come into effect
first of all the closest compact state
is delaware that's useless
completely useless nobody from
delaware's coming up here in a during a
during a state of emergency that would
follow under those conditions they're
just too far away
secondly is that the
you know we we've made we've made a lot
of um
we've made a lot of statements over the
years and we've had a lot of concern and
we've even done it here today about
talking about creating a a solution for
a problem that doesn't exist
the the
the idea of what you would call a
compact in emergency services has
another term it's just called mutual aid
it's existed forever as a matter of fact
i gave a lecture once at the museum in
manchester on
um the longest mutual aid run the city
of manchester ever did and that was to
boston by train
so
you know we've we've had
the emergency services professions have
been dealing with this for 125 years or
more
so what happens is this
if you in a practical example hannover
salem
back even dover
right they interact with agencies from
other states all the time right you get
a major fire in dover you're getting
help from maine it's happening you have
some sort of a you have a plane crash
you have some sort of a significant
event
in salem hanover whatever we we already
have these things worked out
so
and we've been doing it for a long time
where this
compact now becomes a
problem
is that
first of all in order to enact it we'd
have to have some sort of major crisis
occur
that would realistically be handled
before the compact could even come into
to to function because we're not going
to sit here and go sorry mass or you
know we're going to wait on the compact
to get help from delaware before or
pennsylvania or whatever before we
enact what we've been doing for the last
hundred years
the the second problem with that is that
again and i and i brought this up in a
prior part we are now surrendering
control of what we decide to a compact a
compact that involves states most of
which are far west of here well
everybody's far west of here but i'm
talking
you look at who's in the compact right
now it's delaware and it's way out west
so we we would now
and i still can't get an answer because
honestly nobody nobody knows what's
going to happen because we've never
enacted the compact what happens if the
compact is enacted
to the all of the mutual aid agreements
that we've had for 50 80 years
what does that do do those conflict can
they blend do we ignore one over the
other and nobody really knows because
we've never had to do it
so
that's a huge concern for me
in in a profession that has figured this
out
50 to 80 years ago
the other problem here and i i guess
this is an educational moment is the way
that we function
in ems is is a little bit different so
when you take your national registry
certification that's that's just a
certificate that just says hey you know
what you meant the basic competency
levels of being an emt but when you get
into practice you now fall under the
protocols of the state of new hampshire
which is established by the bureau of
ems
but you also fall under a local local
control so if you work in manchester
your local
control is the elliott hospital if
you're in hanover it's dartmouth if
you're in salem it's split between
parkland and holy family depending on
where the patient wants to go
so
what happens is if you bring in folks
from out of state keep in mind under the
compact they operate under their home
license
not new hampshires not new hampshire's
protocols they operate under their home
and those can be extraordinarily
different in a lot of ways they can
either be more inclusive or less
inclusive
so
that that's
someone i wouldn't expect anybody from
delaware or far out west to understand
what new hampshire's protocols are
but the folks that work in methuen and
the folks that work in
white river junction
you know and the folks in kittery have a
general idea because that's their
regional network
and they know what flies and what
doesn't so
this really
that this is a complete change from that
operational method that we function
under right now
and
i appreciate what representative roy
said about you know the fact that
we don't have vetted outcomes because
we've never had to use it
in the in the case of the compact that's
absolutely true we don't know that we
don't know it the other way as well
what we do know is the past
80 80 plus years of these mutual aid
compacts are used all the time we know
how they function we know how they work
and they've been tweaked and
wiggled for that time period so that's
my big concern is
what are we throwing away
to rely solely on this compact that has
never been enacted that is completely
non-functional for us in new england
right now
and that lends its to the point where i
think it's you know we've talked about
saying well if we have a if we get into
a compact and we don't like it we can
always we can get back out i think this
is a case where we jumped in too early
and let's
see how this let's let's let this
compact actually get to somewhere in our
part of the country before we we start
to rely on this and that's that's the
point of of
the the idea to remove this this is why
the governor supports removing it it's
because it's just not
it's just not functioning whatsoever so
that's that's my deal that's why i
support the removal of of this compact
and
i certainly welcome questions or or
additional comments
representative golan
thank you madam chair and i'll follow up
on representative pearson's um
regards to uh the protocols
um
as a emt and a firefighter we
had to take the
rollout protocol exams through the state
of new hampshire an online course
showing competency and state protocol
during the subcommittee i had asked
about protocols and what would be
followed going forward
and this is the issue i have with these
compacts because being so early on i
don't think
they understand or
they don't know what's truly going on
in these compacts i had asked about
protocols which protocol would be
followed
if someone from out of state came to new
hampshire and how it would go through
from there
first answer i got was
they would follow their home state
protocol
unless
new hampshire decides later on that they
want them to
transfer over into the new hampshire
protocol
and then i was told by new hampshire
that no
they would have to do the state protocol
exam
prior to
being able to
provide care here in the state so nobody
seemed to know what the answer was in
this compact as to following protocols
and that's key when you're talking about
ems and you're talking about
care
in a state
so this for that reason i mean i i i
don't think i think we have mutual aid
agreements this has worked well for for
years here in new hampshire and we have
surrounding states that are willing to
help out um if we need more than that
from either further out of state um in a
time of a dire emergency we see that the
executive orders work with temporary
licensure and
reducing the restrictions as people come
up and are needed to help here in new
hampshire so i think i think this is
premature um
i'm not sure that those that are
involved actually know how their compact
is working when i
got this answered and um for that reason
i can i'll i'll support the repeal
right remember
uh thank you uh
uh madam chair um a couple of things one
is um on the issue of their the closest
one is delaware
and that uh we should wait until
somebody's closer i think there's a
certain amount of chicken and egg
problem there
i mean if that was the main argument
against it i would
discount it because um
you know other states here might not
want to join it if there's nobody else
around and if we are out of it
you know it's it's kind of a thing where
there's got to be some first movers and
uh
and then you see what happens maybe
nobody
close to us will ever join it in which
case the thing will
basically have no effect but there's no
opportunity or less of an opportunity
anyway for closer states to join if we
choose to get out of it
uh the other one is i may have missed
something but
my take during the subcommittee meeting
was that um
somebody coming here would have to
follow the new hampshire protocols and
that's similar to the other
compacts we have like the ones we just
voted on
for the
occupational therapy and speech
pathologists and audiologists
you know those
if they're going to practice in new
hampshire do you have they're under the
new hampshire rules
and i believe that's true of the other
compacts although maybe i missed
something in the subcommittee hearing
and that's all i have at the moment
thank you
representative roy
thank you a couple points
um with regard to the department of
defense um they sure are spending an
awful lot of time on something that um
the opinion is that they don't need to
be involved in they do in fact need to
be involved it does not have to be an
emergency order to activate the compact
the compact is always active
it just with regard to normal employees
they can't take regularly scheduled
shifts with the exception of the
military
this is an important issue to the
military for a couple of reasons
one for our own citizens new hampshire
spouses of military members assigned
across the country that are involved in
the compact states can get their
licensure using the new hampshire
certification and vice versa
the military clearly told us when they
do base grading
which they do every year they issue a
report card on bases and one of the main
criteria is how friendly it is to
spouses and family members of military
deployed
and that comes into decisions with
regard to base closing or expanding
bases particularly the f-35 joint strike
fighter whether it goes to portsmouth or
it goes to burlington that's a huge
influx of money to our state
that could go to vermont simply because
you know we we don't rate quite as
highly because we make this decision or
if they come down to closing bases
all things being equal they're going to
look at the states that are more
friendly to the families of spouses of
military members
so it is a reality for the military
um second of all with regard to how
close the states are we heard testimony
that um colorado used this uh during the
wildfires they had emts out there under
the license compact assisting
um
so
i don't think geography is necessarily a
bar and the more states that join the
more it's going to be
used hopefully if necessary we heard
testimony that there's several states
this year who are considering this
we are not considering this we already
considered it and passed it into law and
the governor signed it and i have not
heard that the governor supported
repealing it as a matter of fact i heard
to the contrary um
mostly uh because of the fact that it
it um fits into his general scheme of
things with this covert emergency and
for the military reasons
so this is this is definitely important
everything i've heard against it
everything i've heard to pull out of it
are things that might possibly could
maybe at some point cause a problem but
nothing definitely concrete
we did hear testimony clear testimony
that they had to practice under the new
hampshire
license rules because
someone can't just show up here and hang
out a shingle and say i'm an emt they
have to practice underneath someone as
representative pearson said underneath
the hospital or an ambulance company
and for them to be able to practice they
have to meet the new hampshire standards
so someone can't come here with a kansas
emt license
and just start practicing the kansas way
which may be better or worse they have
to meet the new hampshire stat standards
of practice because they're practicing
underneath someone so all the arguments
still to this very minute to pull us out
of this compact are all
well it could possibly be bad well it
could possibly be very good and pulling
out of it could possibly be bad so i
would ask everyone to really think about
why would we get out of something we put
a lot of work and study into getting
into
simply because
it might not be so good we're not sure
but we know it's got positive upsides so
i would ask everyone to really think
about this
wanting to pull out of it just because i
mean the same people
um
could have made these arguments several
years ago i know one of them did but
others didn't
to not get into this in the first place
and those arguments were vetted
and
so i would i would ask everyone to vote
to i tell this thank you
thank you
respond to some of the things new
hampshire did make the first move in the
region and no one followed
so
this this has existed for several
several years in under when it was
passed and it would the enaction date
that that has come by
um
a year and a half ago but nobody else
followed so we did make the first move
we did throw the dangle the carrot out
and no one took a bite the other thing
as far as
um
this protocol you've got to look at the
protocol the protocol for new hampshire
says it has to be emergency use only if
you come here from kansas
and you want to practice as an emt you
have to get a new hampshire license you
can't use the compact to do that and
that's an important part this compact is
very different from what with the
ideologists that we just use as an
example
that this is not a standard way of doing
business this is emergency use only
vermont as a comparison you know you
talk about the f-35 vermont's not in the
compact so
i mean if we're if we're looking at it
making the state of new hampshire more
enticing that then then we're worried
about being competitive with those
around us again nobody around us does
this so
i don't think it's a factor in that
regard and and i will reiterate again
the bureau of ems told me
that if you're a military spouse and you
come here as a nationally registered emt
you're going to get
in less than one week
so there's no there's there's no barrier
for military spouses to come in here in
practice at all
if they're getting their license in less
than a week
that it's a matter of taking getting
hired and taking a protocol exam you're
done
so
again this is this is just
it was something that was a bill of
goods that was sold and it's just not
panned out
and i and like i said the fear that i
have is that this is
this has really never been fully vetted
as to what's going to happen with the
mutual aid agreements with the
surrounding
communities the surrounding states
representative
thank you madam chair um i did find the
department of defense liaison's
testimony to be compelling
and he actually convinced me that what
we likely need to do
on that issue and i i'm also hearing
what representative pearson is saying i
think we need a separate piece of
legislation
to look at licensing overall and see
and
perhaps study but
do an assessment
formally or informally just make sure
that those
licensing procedures etc
are welcoming of military families i
know we don't have as many as we used to
but i do find it very relevant and that
actually convinced me to uh support this
provision
of this bill so
um
you know hearing the concerns that
representative roy is stating i i do
agree that that is a concern and i think
we need to actually make that piece
bigger
and i don't think that that is necessary
um for this for this piece and i do
support the
um repeat
repeal i guess you'd say um support this
portion of the bill
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and and well i
just want to respond to the comments
that the individuals will have to
practice on the new hampshire protocol i
i understand that was what we got from
the
bureau of ems but the initial response
and i believe it was someone from the
interstate compact themselves who said
that the person would be practicing
under their home state and that's the
point i wanted to make that
the left doesn't know what the right is
doing but it doesn't appear that way
from those comments it's the only reason
i made that statement
and second of all um going back to
military personnel
under this compact
there are three lines dealing with the
military personnel
or three sections an a b and c um and i
see no reason why we have to be a
compact state to implement what these a
b and c state now be brief
veterans service members separating from
active duty military and their spouses
member states shall consider a veteran
active military service member and
member of the national guard reserve
separating from active duty tour
and a spouse thereof who holds a current
valid and unrestricted
nationally registered emt certification
at or above the level of state license
being sought as satisfying the minimum
training and examining requirements
for such licensure b membership states
shall expedite the processing of
licensure applications submitted by
veterans active military service members
and members of the national guard and
reserve separating from the active duty
tour in their spouses
and see finally all individuals
functioning with privilege to practice
under this paragraph remain subject to
the adverse actions provisions of
paragraph eight
now i read that madam chair and i look
at it and i say why do we have to have a
compact state to do those things
we could put that in our own statutes
without having to be in the compact
state i don't know if anybody actually
ever read any of this that's in here
this current statute as to what it means
with military personnel but we don't
need to be in a compact to do those do
those things
um so i'd be happy to if
we get out of this compact
to uh sponsor the legislation to put
this into our statutes the same language
so that we are doing that
to uh
alleviate the dod's
um problems with getting out of a
compact thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair well uh
this is obviously a very thorny issue
but
uh i
want to throw in a couple of examples
uh
that
have not been addressed yet uh one of
our former colleagues
former representative mark prue who was
on the subcommittee
together with me as a matter of fact
that
originally processed the
the bill
to set up the compact
that we're now talking about repealing
um
i contacted him
and he said that he was not in favor of
getting back out again out of it
but he also
reminded me of a couple of things
uh that i was aware of but had not
occurred to me and namely uh
i don't think this is not a mutual aid
situation
uh that representative pearson mentioned
a moment ago
where
firefighters
get called in to fight fires
or other similar emergencies
representative former representative
prue uh was out in california
and i recall that he also went down to
uh puerto rico
damn that phone
went down to puerto rico
and texas during
hurricanes uh where
in the case of
the hurricanes in in
the south and in puerto rico
that was down there
they had an emergency we didn't have
that emergency
california had the fires
they had that emergency we didn't have
that emergency so it's not like that
like the pandemic
where
it got the whole country
so
that's an example of the kind of
situation where the distance also
doesn't make any difference such as uh
the fact that delaware is not right
around the corner but california is not
right around the corner puerto rico's
not right around the corner texas is not
right around the corner yet uh
mark prue was involved in all those
things because they required emts not
firefighters
so uh just for consideration so i'm uh
i it seems to me that what
representative roy said earlier that uh
we barely just got this thing activated
uh and getting out of it on
hypotheticals
uh doesn't seem wise to me so i'm going
to vote to strike the bill
thank you madam chair
i think this is a question for our two
firefighters um
correct me
there are four well i guess we have
three yeah
correct me if i'm wrong i believe
that emts
are
are called emts licensed as emts by
national standards is that not true
[Music]
the national
standards are the minimum requirements
that's where they get the training
and then they are likely staffed by the
state
to work for a specific agency
but you do need a national
license in order to
operate communication yes yes thank you
yes
and
i'd like to mention that from the
testimony
it appeared that this compact
was not so much
helpful for bringing
other safe people into new hampshire it
was to help new hampshire people
licensees working outside the state in
an emergency we heard stories
as representative schmidt said of
people working in hurricanes or forest
fires and because they were working in
compact states
they had the ability to use their new
hampshire credentials
and that i think is important
that we that when our people are called
into other states they are able to work
to the full extent of their license
okay representative ryan and pearson
thank you um
i'm not going to reiterate i mean i
think everyone knows where i stand on
this but i was wondering since we did it
for the previous bills could we possibly
um allow
i believe the head of the state ems is
in the participant list if we if we
could get someone in just because we
seem to be having difficulty uh
reinterpreting testimony from the
subcommittee
and if we could get some maybe direct
answers to a couple of these direct
questions such as scope of practice and
things like that it might be helpful for
the whole committee to hear it straight
from the horse's mouth
if there's anyone
at this meeting who can answer those
questions please
representative pearson
a couple things the
under under katrina we'll use the
hurricanes as an example they did not
practice
down there under the compact they
practice with the national response plan
and provisions of fema
that so that let's not confuse the
compact with with emergency procedures
at the federal level because they are
not the same
they are not even close to the same so
so
but the national response plan and the
provisions in fema aren't going anywhere
they're irrespective of the contest
other questions comments issues
i haven't seen anyone here who would be
able to answer your questions
representative roy
so we'll have to go by our memories and
our judgment
um
if i may
so my
and my inclination is to let the thing
stay in place unless we
you know unless there are actual
problems that are found and it appears
there might be some benefits to it
it's not clear that there are existing
significant problems i mean if there are
problems that show up in the future i'd
you know certainly be open to uh getting
rid of it at that time but uh you know
balancing whatever those other problems
are versus
any benefits and and maybe it will turn
out that it's not worth having but
you know i you can you can maybe we've
dangled a carrot but so given the speed
of legislative processes and they have
to dangle out there for quite a bit
longer before anything happens in the
end it may not but
i
my suggestion is to in my plan is to
just leave it out there for for now
madam chairs uh mr real is i recall that
name is being someone i see him in the
participants list he's the president
yes he's the president of the
firefighters union he didn't answer the
request
he
didn't answer the request to
answer questions
okay
there was one other but okay if no one's
raising their hand then we'll just have
to go with what we know
okay
all right any
further comments questions
are just something here i'd just like to
close um oh i just like the committee to
notice that the those that were in
opposition to this repeal were all
private ambulance companies and not a
single municipal emergency service came
forward
to say that we needed to keep
this complex
which municipality
lebanon i don't was that in the
subcommittee because i didn't hear them
in the regular i don't know if they
spoke they said right testimony
then i apologize i didn't see that
lebanon
and i would think that state ems
could speak for for a vast majority of
the state i don't think they're an
entity uh island unto themselves
all right so in that case the question
the motion is
to legislate which would remove section
two from senate bill 133
i just wanted to say
i don't understand
the amount of fire associated with this
bill is just doesn't this section this
just doesn't seem to be warranted the
issue isn't that great
okay it's just a comment
all right
fine
motion is itl upon section two
and
one
representative right
yes
clerk yes representative pearson no
representative representative
yes
uh representative bailey
representative lanzaro
no
representation
yes
representative goalie
no
referee
representative judy
oh
yes
representative schultz
no
representative fellows
representative front note
no
representative grota
representative o'brien
no
uh i will go back to representative roda
no answer uh represent the chair yes
hey loses hey
okay
i have a motion yeah we'll ought to pass
on uh
okay
motion made off to pass by president
pearson second by brookside
is there anyone who feels to me speak on
this this motion
no okay in that case
what yes
okay um
representative roy
no
no representative pearson yes
representative jacob
no
representative lucas no
representative allegro
yes
representative bailey
no
uh representative lanzaro
yes
representative santo mestaso now
representative goalie
yes
a representative schuett
representative judy
we
representative schmidt
no
representative schultz
yes representative fellows
yes
representative
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
okay the chair no
okay this time it's um
one two eight
all right motion passes eleven to eight
i think we can do our session 13
certified food protection managers
representative
um i make a motion to pass otp section
13.
no amendment excellent i'll second that
would you speak to your motion um yeah
sure this is something we're trying to
move into statute
because
it's been partially in the rules it's
been partially delegated to towns and
it's very inconsistent
um days from town to town sometimes day
to day depending on
who the manager the health manager in
charge of the town is
so i think this is a good idea to
help small shops
with actually hiring teenagers
thank you
and i i'd like to say that
yes they're granting waivers on this but
i think it is important when we see that
there's a
bunch of
places in the same position
that instead of relying on a waiver we
specifically say
these this type of
uh
business
doesn't you know the waivers aren't
necessary we'll just accept them off the
top
and for example
right now if you're in a restaurant with
a significant bar business
your restaurant the kitchen may close
down hours before the rest
this would allow your food protection
manager to leave when the kitchen closes
instead of being stuck there until one
o'clock in the morning every night
and so i think that's a
very reasonable accommodation
so i'm fully in support of this
anyone else have a comment question
i'm allegra
i'm going to largely say what you said i
think that the way this is structured
now it just
captures two
diverse uh
a field
places that sort of coffee and donuts
are not the same as places that are
preparing food from lawns
thank you madam chair um i'm opposed to
this bill
there's already a procedure for getting
a variance to
this rule you just go through the
food service bureau at hhs
and
they can work with a business to develop
a variance
that's specific to the needs of of the
particular business
and
this
it's and i also agree that it's
completely
reasonable
to give variances to food establishments
particularly those that um
have only served foods that are low risk
in terms of causing illness like a like
a places that do only ice cream or just
like aroma joe's because they only have
the coffee and the bagels
but
my concern is that well i have two
several concerns
one of them
and i just need to mention that aroma
joe's already has a variance
they've got they have variances for at
least some of their establishments and i
think all of their establishments
and so i'm concerned about getting into
the practice of putting variances in
statute
this particular variance
might work for aroma joe's but
might not necessarily
work very well for for other
establishments and are we going to get a
line of different businesses coming and
asking us to put
something that they can get a variance
for into statute the
the idea of having variances to rules is
that the people at the state agencies
who know whatever this
um area of of business or practice or
food safety whatever it is that's where
the experts are they can make a decision
about what is
a variance that continues to protect the
public at the same time that the helps
the business be able to operate
and this this request came from just one
business
um
by exempting
all food establishments
that have fewer than
six people
handling the food is going to exempt
i my guess is more than half the
restaurants in this state
um is because the people who handle food
generally are not the wait staff so it's
just the people who are cooking the food
and you know there might be somebody
doing prep
so that it excludes a huge number of
restaurants it excu it excludes places
that serve sushi
which is
a food that can be
potentially dangerous
and it excludes restaurants that serve
seafood
shellfish
oysters things like that i think that
this is um
this putting this in statute
jeopardizes
public safety of in particular i'm
thinking about restaurants people who go
to restaurants
and i just think it's it's uh
inappropriate to just
start putting things that could be
granted as variants in statute
i'm sorry did you call me
yes
okay i have a question about um
how does this bill
help with hiring more teenagers
i'm not sure it does why
is isn't that what representative
yakubovich said
yeah
please then i believe small shops will
be able to do so
coffee shops where no me uh major
expertise is needed to cook food
to serve coffee
okay so follow up follow up
um so in the first section we're saying
that
we don't there there does not need to be
a food protection manager
um
when i'm sorry in section b
there doesn't need to be a food manager
there when there's no food being
prepared that's what we're saying in
section
in section one
right
and then what we're saying is it doesn't
need to be a food manager there
if the food is already prepared
or is ready to eat
right
correct
correct that's what it says then we see
i'm sorry
that's what it says go on yes and we're
saying that
if there's five food employees there
you're not required to have
the food side this was if there's five
food employees there
the food manager food protection manager
doesn't need to be there but he needs to
be available
is that right
yes that's what it says
so why bother with one two and one and
two because number three covers
everything
even a very large restaurant with many
food
preparation employees
might well want to let the food
protection manager take the evening off
after the kitchen closes
well that's not in here because it says
food establishment having five food
employees or less that doesn't include i
mean
all hours of operation
that says that the food protection
manager has to be available on call
all the for all hours of operation
yes i understand the medium chair which
is why i'm saying isn't it doesn't
number three cover one and two
no it does not
represent the lack
i just think that we're looking at this
from the
exact opposite way should be looked at
or at least in some cases we are we're
not putting variance into statute
what we're doing is narrowing down
current statute that's overly broad
and then the second thing that comes to
my mind is as legislators why are we
sitting here being contented with making
so many small businesses jump through
hoops
just because the current statute is
overly broad and yes they can get a
variance but it's not our job it's not
our role to be making these small places
that should be exempt
jump through the hoop
of getting a bearing
and that's all i'm going to be uh
supporting this thank you representative
yes thank you madam chair i'm sorry but
um
a distance away and i have to leave
thank you for your your uh
your time
thank
you we won't finish the rest this will
be the last section for today
representative schultz
oh i was just going to say to
representative allegro we should debate
the federalist papers sometime i think
it would be fun i do think we do have
the responsibility for safety of course
and i just think we're gonna agree to
disagree on some aspects of our
philosophy towards government and
regulation and that's
all okay thank you
i'd like to comment that the bulk of
this regulation is not in statute it's
in rules
and therefore but statute trump's rules
and therefore we this is the way only
way we can influence it
representative fellows do you have uh
something bad
um i just wanted to clarify
that it when you look at this um how
it's printed
one a the part that says a person um
let's see
somebody has to be present
who's a certified food protection
manager uh when
has let's see
yes during during hours of operation
that is
already in rules and the second part
be
that says they don't have to be there if
if there's no food preparation going on
is already in the rules so those two
things are not changing anything the
change comes with item number two and
three that says
you know this they need somebody on
staff but he doesn't have to be there
all the time that's new
and
and and i point out that
it says they don't have to they're on
staff but they don't have to be there
it's like well how often do they have to
even visit the place can they visit just
once a year
and um the second part about
the exemption of
five or under food handlers that's
new that's different from the rules so
the first two are already in the rules
the second two are
are really what we're debating because
that's the thing that's making a change
thank you thank you representative
thank you madam chair if this is already
in rules
then why not just change the rules
or or amend the rules and not go through
this process
at least partly representative because
the rules are not under our control
all we can do is ask
the agency to change the rules
and there is no
guarantee that they will understand our
concerns
but in other times
we allow
rules to make their own decisions so i
don't know why we're not allowing that
now
that's a good question you'll have to
wonder i mean the point is what should
be in statute what should be in rules
work is
a is a complicated issue but
i for one prefer to give the agency
better guidance than
uh
some than some people who write laws and
i think they should be
aware of and responsive to legislative
concerns
you are free to take a different opinion
and there are in fact rules on this that
are actually not being enforced for
smaller operations
and i
strongly disagree with
relying on selective prosecution
to
uh
to deal with an issue that should be
settled by
exemptions and
necessary variances and this is an
exemption
thank you i do think that this kind of
debate is important to have
and i appreciate
your response thank you madam chair
other
concerns questions
represent scitec
would any business fulfilling two and
three be denied a waiver
if the waiver is essentially automatic
why don't we why
would
we put people through the waiver process
why don't we just testify for one thing
it also this would if it's in statute
it also applies to
cities and other municipalities that
have their own food service rules
the waiver is only
for the state
it does not apply in a city such as
comfort that has its own inspection
so
make something more severe more
respective congress could do that right
or they could deny a waiver that was
approved by the state
what town does representative fellows
live in
i don't believe it's a city
but i mean it depends on whether people
are available
the town of epsom had a food sanitation
manager
yes i live in holderness
which is near
plymouth and
almost all the restaurants i can think
of
with the exception maybe one has five or
less
but my what i really wanted to say was
that because this is buried in this
omnibus bill we we didn't hear
any testimony from any food
establishment other than aroma joes
and if we go through rules process
then
i think that the people in in the food
industry will have more notice and will
be able to make um comments about you
know what they think of this rule
and
representative fellows i don't know
about you but i spoke to the managers
and owners
of several food service establishments
and they their basic response was oh
please do it
so
uh
that's i ca
that's all i can say about yours
representative bailey
i i could be mistaken but i seem to
recall we heard from the restaurant
association
yes the restaurant association
all right
are there restaurants
she said that
there's fewer than five food service
employees
all right any uh other comments
questions debate
i mean
you can buy sushi at a gas station
that's all that's all i have to say
yes it's an interesting state
okay so the motion is ought to pass on
section 13
of made by america
the clerk will call the roles
representative roy
yes
yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes
representative lonzara yes
representative
yes
representative goalie
representative schuette
yeah i think she's left
yeah she has one she's oh i i didn't
know that i thought she might have
stayed for this representative judy
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz yes
representative fellows
no
representative fund though
yes
representative roda
are you muted are you there
we'll come back representative obama yes
sorry yes
representative o'brien
yes
representative you don't have to be
sorry for voting yes uh representative
mcguire yes
the chair rather uh it is 18 to 1.
okay
i'd just like to add that i've been
inspired to go out to eat tonight by
this
good point
any good places in holderness
i've never been to holding this
that's a that's a call to action by the
way sally yeah oh yeah paul please come
and visit there are a lot of good um
walters basin right on the um
channel between big squam and little
swan i was there last weekend
okay
so that uh
i think that's enough for today
we will be resuming
uh next tuesday
and we will we will be taking up
sections
[Music]
which we haven't had yet in the
non-german amendment working and then
and 14 yes to
so
i i'm not sure that i could hear the
whole thing it may be cut out seven
eight in
twelve seven eight no it's 6 8
and 12 and 14.
14 is the non-germain right
you're missing letters for that
representative scitec
there's the bi the n and the g
and then thursday we've got a couple
subcommittee
there are a couple of subcommittees this
coming thursday
which
uh we will also try if they're through
we will also try to exact
uh i suspect we will need an additional
exec session
after the subcommittees are through
there's also a subcommittee on
next tuesday
on senate bill 155.
could we have the
information that was just communicated
could that be in the form of an email
that will be sent to all of us
it has already been sent to you in an
email and it will be in the calendar
peter you're with me on thursday okay
same same
same difference i i
i
am aware of the subcommittee's on
thursday
the scheduling for tuesday was sent out
earlier i think it was either late last
night or this morning and it will be
next week
okay fine as long as it's in writing i
appreciate that
yeah i got the email during the hearing
today so too much to say okay
so i just i'm still not 100 sure i know
what's going on here
thursday did you say we could exec
might accept exec on bills after the
subcommittee i wouldn't expect to no i
don't plan to
they've got enough work to do
all day on those bills
like 60 people okay so all day
so
is a working day
next tuesday we have a subcommittee in
the morning and the afternoon we'll
start
we'll pick up where we left off on okay
okay
and we'll probably require an additional
exact session
uh which i'm thinking will be the
tuesday afternoon
anyone with strong objections next to
the tuesday after next please let me
know
[Music]
that would be the
18th yeah
that's fine with me
yeah i think we'll definitely need one
because by the time we're done with 133
then we actually have an actual
amendment put together
all right well thank you all for
lasting as long as you did
and uh
madam chair
your star wars day may the fourth yeah
yeah
yeah i did just real quick um everything
we voted on today we are going to have
to vote on again on an official uh as
part of the
once we get the bill all together with
the amendments is that correct
um
when we get the official amendment we
will vote on the amendment
unless it gets divided
which
is possible but i'm not going to
encourage it
right but each
bill like or each section are we going
to take one vote on on bill 133 or as
amended with the giant amendment are we
going to we have to rehash all this
i was planning on taking one vote unless
bailey's it is
[Laughter]
okay have a have a good evening and
i'll see you next tuesday